ça lui s'amuse à lui à tous bienvenue
dollars en six de cet état style
alors je laisse si tu veux nous
présenter le programme du jour les
parties vous commandiez dans les seconds
ardemment yes alors du coup on va avoir
ta ble ment le duel chant clan contre
prague d'amanda donc je pense un duel
assez ouverts ou shankland peut-être
aura envie d'essayer de marquer son
premier petit point contre le loup à
dire le cadet du championnat qui a perdu
hier qui a perdu hier contre richard
rapport voilà pense qu'on va avoir je
pense la partie avant du camés la partie
en tout cas de cette ronde d'être
finalement à west of way moment notre
fil rouge principal de la journée c'est
ça ouais donc carlson champion du monde
face à richard rapport qui en grosse
progression et qui montre d'entendre a
vraiment de très belles choses qui
d'ailleurs en tête du tournoi
donc carlson rapport ça va être hyper
intéressant comme ça qu'ils veulent et
toutes les parties et rapport qui a un
style hyper intéressant et très créatif
dont on va voir un peu comment ça se
passe et puis 40e stouff qui a laissé
filer deux belles occasions lors des
dernières rondes donc là il avait pièce
blanche et va avoir à coeur de lille
doit décoller ouais faut tout
ça je m'en serais parti donc en jeu pour
m'avoir mamediarov contre grand des
lieux donc ça aussi une affiche
intéressante avec un job qui en tête et
qui a les blancs contrat le joueur qui
est dernier du tournoi donc changer les
anciens prix en tout je mettrais bien
une pièce contre toute attente sur
grandes et mieux avec les pièces noires
je sais pas pourquoi sérieux bah ouais
je sais pas il a pu prendre confiance
avec ses adieux contre 15 asnières
métaireau fils en tête mais l'homme de
la réussite pourquoi pas
c'est la grosse ce qu'on dit c'est ma
grosse cote du jour
mais
ok ou en tout cas d'un bureau offre
pieds blancs et sera favori il est en
tête donc c'est quand même un peu une
partie à a pas raté et pour lui c'est
une belle
situation un procès de prendre avantage
dans le camp nou velle avance dans ce
dans cette course au titre dont c'est le
quatrième place en 1/4 yakine qu'on
trouve en dessous reste donc qu'à yakine
dans ce tournoi il a un peu je veux dire
quasiment inexistant un gi joe à grand
chose la partie d'hier était hyper
intéressante pour le coup parce que duda
a voulu jouer la partie est du coup il
ya eu une partie mais mais mais bolacre
car qui n'est que les blancs cointreau
reste est d'ailleurs à propos de cette
partie ils ont répété les coups hier et
on n'a pas à alger finalement des actes
mais au moins la répétition du da avait
un gars
est tout à fait rien parce qu'ils n'ont
pas répéter les coups exactement le
monde pensait les gens un coût plus tard
donc savait juste très germain pulsions
et les deux joueurs ont raté quelque
chose donc duda voilà qui peut s'en
mordre les doigts
et tu regarderas presse tu veux bien
tout ajustement qui a les noirs
aujourd'hui contre-visite vite et donc
qui est co-leader avant peut-être un peu
de culture doit et qui est très solide
ouais
on vous dit blanc donc je pense qu'on va
le sol il va boire un peu ce qui se
passe dans la partie et sans doute un
jeu toujours très dynamique et cette
secousse ressentie sur le point de vue
le donc je pense cette partie
intéressante aussi woodin
en c'est un clasico improbable
caruana guérir il se sont joués je sais
pas combien de fois
bon c'est toujours intéressant à suivre
car elle m'a qui va essayer de démarrer
enfin son compteur avec les blancs il a
fait côté niel jusque là le joueur
américain il
cessa et ont su tuer le du s1 le duel
russe double xp un coût non classé les
deux joueurs qui montent en russie même
si dubaï âgées
il est plus élevé l'acquéreur 22 ans je
pense à moi je dirais plus gérer plus de
4 ce passage ceux qui nous rejoignent
n'hésitez pas neutre
non 96
il a réagi mais plus qu'aux troupes ans
et l'a 25 ans et demi peut être ouais
bon il a il a 25 ans et donc il est
quand même assez jeune et c'était une co
17 ans vont connaître le foot c'est pas
la même génération
c'est ça
donc donc en tout cas il ya pas mal de
parties hyper intéressant toujours dit
et puis on a démâté on sait qu'on va
suivre malgré ces résultats compliqué on
espère qu'il va décoller avec les pièces
blanches et pas forcément à paris qu'en
face il joue dans le challenge aux
contres erwan l'amicale grand maître
néerlandais de 1630 environ
expérimentés donc voilà
y en a marre candrian la chair un petit
peu je pense son jeu j'ai l'impression
depuis le début que si mal joué qu'une
fois qu'il est foutu rohff est basse et
aux sentiments aussi ce taux qui a
trouvé des pelles rupture dans cette
dernière partie mais c'était déjà trop
tard
ouais j'ai l'impression qu'il y ait pas
dans son assiette on se sent moins il
veut du mal à se lâcher
j'aimerais ça aussi
par contre il faut commencer par alors
on peut commencer par par le début par
déjà bonjour à nous rejoignent arnaudin
leur talent salut à tous bienvenue sur
le stream n'hésitez pas à nous écrire
trouve le chat 1 voilà si vous avez des
questions vous le vendez de la question
rangs des partis en particulier on
essaiera de
vous satisfaire
alors
donc on sait par quoi d'abord et c'est
toi une partie avait peut-être quelques
coups de
pouce a conscience mais encore instauré
en scène rapport va pas avoir grand
chose à dire après beaucoup par contre à
partir un petit peu qu est le plus joué
c'est séchant clan pas pour l'instant
ouais c'est un petit globe le ray-grass
le sait se passe pas grand chose et les
italiennes loin de kyoto fixé kavanagh
bizarre voire karama qui joue tout le
temps que tout d'ailleurs au passage
chez chloé une petite caméra numérique
et donc c'est justement je crois que
c'est choquant de prague et de navarre
et parfois il ya une caméra vole un
petit peu attraper les images des
joueurs mais ceux dont on aura tout le
monde a pas à pas du coup dur américain
et le petit indien car ce tout début
le 4 était joué on parle dans une
semaine une swatch niqueurs je crois
cécilienne c'est de penser
et e5 caractérise la vaysse knitter donc
les dix mots sur cette case peu ton
cerveau qui créera rsa peut être même
dans cette ouverture on va voir ce
qu'ont choisi les joueurs stuff connaît
bien toi c'est pour ça qu'on joue gravel
et v5 pour menacer kadhafi dès 6 ans
fait ou ce qui forcerait un petit peu
décider si ce n'est pas forcément plus
un fou b4 existe
et agissons pour donner l'idée
sous des quatre cavaliers des six qui
existe est
bon ça paraît très bizarre en fait ici
des noirs sont pas mal parce que ils ont
gagné entre 1 75 et les français but
pour penser 8 et il y aura des cinq de
jouer là pendant huit mois et chuté puis
on gratifie ciel c'est intéressant ça
joue en tout cas est très cavalier
français vu que c'est pas le meilleur
c'est faux il est pas beau local elle
manger c'est pas la priorité
ouais donc avalé v5
donc menace décision dcc normal la suite
il avait réussi à plusieurs coups
mais donc il ya un flou g5 c'est le
grand coût théorique mais à la mode
depuis qu'arsène joue en fait la
question avec les avec les noirs gwenn
notamment chouchou pas du monde contre
caravaning et ben 45 devenu vachement à
la mode voici ce que je vis comme figure
toi ô connaître la théorie avec les
blues sur cette variante je l'avais sa
loi mais c'est pas mal
bien longtemps et depuis on va forcément
se connectent j'ai montré cette
fourchette l'imparable à part surmonté
vallier esprits et la fameuse question
ou mais ce cheval
alors ce cavalier en fait ça peut
paraître bizarre dont la jugulaire
jusqu'à la lie au 7
mai
normalement le grand coup ce délai en
but par les deux jeunes bambins
le grand coup boc que je karl 16 etc il
est en fait de revenir plus tard sauté
17 donc 7 et 10 et 5 ou d'événements en
u15 des fois j'en ai très souvent les
blancs plus tard jouer les 4 4 donc en
gros on va essayer de réparer pour
revenir à 5 et que le plan f
vient manger le pire aux 5 vous pouvez
laisser comme ça
mais kyle 7 c'est aussi ligne qui se
joue je l'avais travail a pas longtemps
ses carrières et donc c4 mais je crois
que c'est quand même beaucoup moins bien
une chambre que ses bras c'est vraiment
douteux ce qui voudrait pas jusque là
moi je crois que c'est patrice
etchegaray bat internationale et c'est
la bande sonore en france dans le pays
basque est notamment qu'il avait louée
par martin entre une fois je n'ai pas
passé loin d'ailleurs mais moi c'est
quand même jouable à douteux je trouve
que tu veux mais bon je sais pas je
l'avais travail apparemment quand il me
semblait que j'avais vu défiler avec la
mef 3 damas trois à être comme ça qui
était bizarre alors il semble que tout
le monde s'était déjà légèrement
justement une espèce de batteries
colorectal accc a
tout le temps menaçant double échec
évidemment
travail et akanua il a mis son font face
ouais vous avez au bout de la dame on
tape sur la faiblesse des six
dames davis tout pour défendre l'option
mais
russian hqe attachant où était jouée au
cash c'est normal et du coup grâce à
cinq des noir et blanc les bleus gagnent
la casse g5 pour le fou est lui aussi le
pion à 5 peut aussi être faible à voir
comment ça se passe en dessous d'eux sur
la partie d'une pression sur champions
ouais j'ai agrippé désolé on est là
assise donc on va chasser ce clavier
qui revit et je crois on arrive à
comprendre le pion h4 qui était bon je
suis pas sûr que l'on était vraiment
prise parce que j'aurais pu faire après
j'ai trop avec pour preuve chaque mois
ou les
mais ok en jeu solide donc voir un peu
ce qui se passe après donc là on peut
imaginer ou peut-être f5 des noirs
alors elle s'endort en fait ce déficit
en fait là vous voyez bien que dans la
position après après le coatch 5 des
morts et dont on a du mal à papeete rock
il faut prendre et du coup s combineront
c'est une grande question ça
et
là peut-être qu'on laisse au sortir du
court voix sans ressources internes pour
l'instant il va le laisser au centre
donc moi j'aime bien un plan avec f 5 fu
et 6 et un jour peut-être même ce 4 e 5
essais de ramener les caisses comme ça
ça fait c'est un plan de temps d'avancé
dans ce type de position
mais je sais pas trop donc là on voit
bien que les blancs des
majorités ll dame donc son 4e
est lui et progressistes quoi voilà je
peux paraître en demies rouge l'option
des ses semelles lisses et hélas
telle question malgré sa lutte
c'est le green
pense que compte france va gagner alors
jusqu'où il ira car
ses chances je pense que j'ai plus de
chances que cry gaz était mort plutôt
que 23 ans gagne une terrine se bat là
je pense que c'est
en tout cas une ouverture intéressante
autant dans cette partie je suis encore
bien qu encore gagné dans ce tournoi
donc là c'est sûr ça des appariements
sur le papier les plus abordables pour
lui avec les pièces blanches donc il va
essayer un
vieux et donc en espoirs à jouer avec de
bons coups ouais
je pense après f5 des idées comme à 4 à
5 on est blanc avec cavaliers à quatre
cavaliers b6 ont fixé sur casino ti blé
donc l'idée vraiment se laisser 2-2
d'empêcher afin de bouger moi ça me
dérange vraiment se plonge 5 chez les
noirs qui fait qu on a vraiment du mal à
défendre ce roi quoi je pars ok mais
quand tu mets kg cistre pas trop te
permettre de te prendras shon quoi sinon
mes placards c'est pour ça que cette
ligne mais certaines techniques et sa
manche pour cabaye et adil à la mort il
a joué on voit la caméra
l'autre côté tu vois un coup ok ou
tranchant avait 5 immédiatement il met
la pression il sacrifie peut être
potentiellement pions puisque conception
bay south attaqué quatre fois
seulement trois défenseurs
avoir invité on va regarder peut-être du
peloton comptait maintenant balle ok ça
a été pris instantanément à part ça me
choque landes qui est pas du tout
surtout des cadeaux c'est à dire ikua on
voit que le joueur bercail 1h46 temps
qu'il a gagné 6 minutes depuis le début
de la partie des beats sa prépa at-elle
bourg
il me semble kevin que même quand tu ou
commentaire mais patatras c'est le bon
coup
donc c'est pas l'excusé du commentaire
pas de commentaires je crois que tu es
comme ça quoi qu'il arrive
au passage que j'aime tant que tu es là
est ce que tu peux nous dire si le son
et les goudes
je sais que tu as un expert en la
matière je suis devenu un expert en la
matière à propre et cinq cavaliers
professeur il a été encaissée secours au
sam et du coup il est beau bon écoute à
terre dressait une option va serrer al
adha
donc là il joue très très vite comme
tous les deux donc une position qui
accumule a reconnu par les deux joueurs
ouais mais
marc gascon les conversations ici pour
les noirs se trouve en
fait
100 euros que j'ai vraiment du mal quoi
est ce coût pourrait pas ok quand même
maintenant que ce fou car il doit à tout
prix garder un oeil sur le cavalier donc
peut-être que l'europe étoffe maintenant
well tareen c'est pas du foot j call les
blues doivent quand même se dépêtrer un
peu sur clouage puisque même à quatre
juste pour montrer ça défend pas
vraiment le cavalier et un autre clou
âge ce pion finalement il sait pas grand
chose donc plus important
peut-être que le rock est possible ouais
ok super pour le feu vert de tête cet
été
je propose qu'on va un petit peu quand
même laissé les deux joueurs avant cette
fraude chez moi et on va aller voir
maintenant que des coups joués sur une
autre partie notre affiche du jour entre
15 à des rapports pièce
alors bachmann
a eu quarante six coups non plus un mais
car celle qui est restée fidèle à son
cavalier 3 il avait déjà joué avant de
forest stouff
donc tout en souplesse bien peut voir
comment comme le jour rapports et
choisir dans quel système rentrée
donc je dégage derrière et finalement on
va se poser
donc je crois quand même rendre dans les
grandes lignes et des choses notamment
qu'il a un petit peu déjà tenter un tour
du
monde assad et poway j'étais passé
quelque chose comme
fou j'ai deux cavaliers 6 ha ok
intéressant petit rock tour des huit ou
trois bombes évidente précoce ce tour
benneteau pour tout de suite évitez les
poires dans cette grande diagonale est
menacée bay 5-1 et menacé de consolider
ce pion condamné en question ses cartes
parce que juste montre un petit peu à la
place de tourbe et utile avec the bay 5
directement il aurait pu avoir des comme
cavalier le 5 et à celle avec le vide et
la tour et ça aurait pu poser problème
donc du coup les noirs s'enlève de la
diagonale à 14 pour menaces et aux baies
5 qui défendrait le pion et en plus on
lève la diagonale donc c'est vraiment un
coup très malin
ici on pourrait simplement projet pas de
problème parce que le flux de le pourrai
manger sur le web
donc tourbe éviter qu'un seul avoué 3 il
a défendu son maillot or juste un petit
mot français
restent parmi nos invités beck le fou
devant le hongrois
mais ça c'est surtout quand notre hôte
fou de gaz rouge il veut développer de
manière plus normal quand on fait un
gâteau c'est ok il n'ya pas de blocus
ici d'un rongeur est ce qui te faire sur
une chute de reach at
excuse moi ça m'a le fait de lire le
message de kevin m'a donné la touche
fut étouffée j'espère qu'il va bien son
blog était une belle gifle pour
l'instant les dispositifs ouais mais
normalement mais pour l'instant nous en
serions là il s'est marié ce bal ce
variant là il est pas trop trop méchant
n'étant pas avoir le plus de protéger je
suis allez paris et ça c'est beau
mais pas sedan et retournons du cobra
cette ouverture
auquel magnus c'est le verra pas
réfléchi ce fou à droite jean garrigues
peu dans
la position est assez rare à il faut 3
c'est clairement ce tour
jusqu'ici dans ma base j'avais 500
parties dans cette position et
autres points était joué une seule fois
alors là oui encore une fois j'ai c'est
une petite base sépariez pas les parties
mais ces bonnes indicateurs le coût
principal ses cavaliers c3 qu'elle était
joué la moitié du temps les autres coûts
sont de 3 e 4 les autres principaux
thèmes du food g5 il faut 3 c'est le 2 3
4 5 6 7 8 le dixième coûts internes de
deux fréquences mais
ça explique en tout cas la réflexion de
rapport a
donc surpris par cette idée de carcela
ont baissé de réfléchir déjà pourquoi on
ne pourrait pas finalement tout de suite
en bts ou
dut d'après toi
alors j'aurai ma de la base un moment
d'y pourvoir 1 mais fou 3 gt le plein de
fois chez moi
petite base ah ouais mais voulait trop
triste ouf quand même
[Musique]
parti tu vas sur 500 parti s'était joué
qu'une fois donc c'est quand même un
pourcentage
micro
ouais alors chez moi et j'ai quand même
beaucoup de fois en fait elle a ramené
sa position dans sa base
je peux le voir ou pas je vous reconnais
un ordre d'idée ah non en fait non
pardon j'ai déjà expliqué me sens pas
bien mais oui j'ai quand même quelques
parties et les internautes notamment une
partie shop en top 12
entre deux deux amis français ah
ouais donc j'ai une partie est fou aux
trois
de paul velten ok bon kick au magal et
viser à skis mais c'est le grand maître
fab il avait joué quoi fabriquer des 5
ou le cet os est ok et tranquille est en
fait la partie alors qu'on savait faire
et tu nous confirment qu'il faut trois
savoir ça correctement parce qu'en fait
la position avec jean bart une autre
position avant actualisé mais là c'est
vrai que la psyché par lots varia la
cause ou le qu'il a joués voulu s'en
remettre à croître et après il ya eu
quelques il ya un autre grand maître à
24,50 qu'il a joué mais c'est ok mais
donc ça reste des toutes petites
proportions et donc moi cavaliers t5 ici
c'est le premier qui me vient à l'esprit
pour iliad a profité de la position de
ce fou est ce que finalement l'idée
c'est pas de doute que 15 laisse son
foulard de rbo géant je sais pas où moi
je pensais peut-être afu d2 pour te dire
peut-être qu'on va gagner le temps plus
tard sur le cavalier quand on jouera au
4 et revenir ont été ensuite je sais pas
après jc dans dans ses positions
après bon je sais pas quels sont les
liens ouais c'est pas mais il reste dans
cette position-là 4 on n'a pas forcément
ou de trop vite actuellement par serge
bloch le ça bloque le fou si j'ai deux
et
quatre ans n'est pas forcément si
contents de jeu
campus quand je veux tu as très bien tu
donnes la case d3 aussi gérer les bêtas
cavaliers detroit qui peut arriver il y
avait une partie comme ça d'ailleurs pas
si tu viens aux olympiades avec ses
joues de boussard avec les noirs il
avait réussi un parc est un cavalier en
d3 contre qui
pour ça je sais plus et met à jouer pas
te dire ok mais il leur restait matin
cavale en d3 dans cette position il y
avait 1 88e pour nature est donc en
mettre quatre ça donne des gaz au final
et ça bloque le fouet c'est pas vraiment
enfin c'est pas sûr que ce soit un coup
qu'on a vraiment tous les jours au
mixeur avec toi d'accord très bien
curieux de voir la réaction de rapport
aux pertes sur prairies l'appel chez
derrière ça c'est intéressant se
poursuit la partie contre attaque il a
fini par remporter l'a reconnu qu'ils
n'étaient pas très contents de comment
s'était passée l'ouverture mais après il
avait réussi à surclasser son jeune
adversaire vous savez plusieurs fois un
peu les ouvertures sur un peu complexe
pour le joueur hongrois on va voir la
c6 en sort il prend son temps en temps
on va aller voir notre parti et qu'est
ce qui te ferrandi
alors voilà j'ai pas trop 2 et pourrait
progrès kevin écoute moi je suis chaque
seconde en or après je pense que je
serais plus utile cet aspect si ou autre
que pour les ouvertures jeu
au terme des vitesses
alors battus avec un règlement
correspond
toujours au rang d'homme caisse
il a reproché à recommencer fois arrivé
à baby de bombes on peut le deviner mais
il voulait pas se faire manger je sais
pas c'est l'arrêt avant la ronde le but
c'est parce qu'à reprocher sauf autres
cases noires et il est bien caché il est
bien au chaud il va passer l'hiver est
pas y'a pas de problème
on va on va voir comment on en est
arrivé là
où carrière tim k je veux 4
on est parti sur de l'italienne
a quand même encore pas mal bu 1 depuis
le début de ce tournoi avec les fameux
à 5 toujours pour donner
des casots fou et freiner l'expansion
blanche à l'aide d'armes
donc l'enjeu à chaque fois c'est souvent
de le premier qui arrive à poser aux
hommes qui peut prendre une petite
initiative
normalement les blancs plus de facilité
grâce à l' avantage du 13
avril à anticiper d'ailleurs une fois
cette
idée comme ça contre à vide et il s'est
fait manger sur canal que ça on a vu ça
plus tôt dans le tournoi il n'avait par
spectaculaire qu'elle attend du cloud
par quand même brillé à trois quarts à
kienké jour fut solide quand même à
5,8
et donc ses gâchettes belleville des 4
alors bon ici c'est un peu moi je met le
front des vite très moche même mêlé d je
pense clairement de
forrest cavalli à terme et après le show
ces le cavalier est de gagner un temps
sur le cavalier et le fou avec ses 6 et
des cinq donc la version être ça le fou
qui parlait d'ailleurs délation le sur
le roi h 2
mais ici bonne réaction des blancs qui
vous des 4 1 c'est logique marson sont
pas encore bien développée avec baby tu
viens pour
s'excuser du centre eux-mêmes pas de
raison de retard 17 chez central se
trouve en général quand on peut y aller
qu'il ya pas de concrétisation au x y
aller pas avoir peur mais là j'ai géré
au kg une tour en un jeu les pièces bien
placé et les noirs des enfants le roi en
8e fois en début août on a envie d'y
aller et il a géré la rocqué en retour à
vannes forest s'est mise en noir était
sous contrôle
et on a une position finalement
peut-être un peu moins classiques que
d'habitude dans cette ouverture grâce à
cette particularité que ces camions à ce
qui existe
or si on joue un coup comme à troyes qui
pourra paraître logique qui empêche tout
g4 et sait comment le noir vont
engendrer parce que si je joue cavalier
c'est parce que moi je sais que j'aurai
fait cavalier seul cavalier g6 et après
farce et 6 et le prime c'est que ce fait
cavalier 7 ben je parlais contrôle du
pion aux 5
le couple quel vêtement plan peut-être
trop vite les taureaux et je pourrais
pas faire cavalier cette non plus
rejeter cavaliers à cette annonce par
ailleurs a pris 0,5 et 1 point dans huit
excavatrices et parfois je pense par là
tu peux manger en d4 si après tout ce
que j'ai des cinq jeunes amants de la
scène alors que c'est quelqu'un que
avoir peut-être que gênante manche tu
manges pas en d4 c'est juste pour manger
quoi il retourne en arrière je mange
ansa ont déclassé pour avoir une
réaction d'arrière avec ses 5 ou des
cinq donc sa prisé des ça ça parait
intéressant ouais
son public et je pense que je regardais
les prends je crois que je mange du
cavally et qu'après je préfère c'est si
ces dessins comme ça c'est possible que
la partie se poursuivre comme ça alors
bien sûr que carrière qu'il jouera je
crois même sexe un coup on a souvent vu
comme foukhari roger carte ça pose pas
mal de problèmes sur ce pion en fait il
ya une tension au centre donc le
cavalier f3 et la dame des âges jouent
un rôle capital par apport à 60 ils
défendent tous les deux le centre et sa
cape rouge et quatre jeux réussir à
enlever pas potentiellement deux
défenseurs
du cuir des quatre notamment l'afp randa
me prend elle canalise l'éliminer et la
dame d'étang plus on peut donc la déco
bon là je sais pas s'il ya quelque chose
hein mais en tout cas pas cette idée en
corse calvi qui défend donc oui c'est le
cas je dis pas obligatoire
mais
ouais
ok position peut-être intéressant de
voir comment ça se décante en forêt sont
à vue qu'il n'avait pas peur de jouer
avec les couleurs de prendre des risques
avec les noirs content car c'est de
l'envoyer deux pions donc ya pas de
raison ici que s'ils jouent aux petits
bras c'est l'opportunité lui ai laissé
en tout cas de prendre des risques
peut-être qu'il va un blues est un
combat à caraquet et peut-être que
karine justement il va finir par nous et
par nous démentir et et tenter un petit
peu de de faire des choses moi avec les
plombs
oui réponse dans les prochaines 12
heures sur qui on bat plus tôt alors
donc on peut aller voir ce qu eux
caruana gear et carole aguerri qui a été
joué en ouverture un petit peu spécial
mais ça m'étonne de caruana qui joue ça
c'est peut-être la tête de série numéro
2 contre la numéro 3 du tournoi
peut-être je pense peut-être
et caruana donc équitation est un
véritable caméléon ou la wii cavalière 3
il a fait un double fond du cateau
derrière c'est pas dans ses habitudes
étonnant béthouart
si fabi le petit famille est ce qu on
l'a déjà vu jouer b3 pâti comme ça par
orbite
basse et même pas deux mais trois ans
après cette victoire en doutions que
tout cas là pour le coup
après il ya un gros historique entre les
deux joueurs et son jeu beaucoup de soin
et je pense que là il n'est pas l'idée
c'est assez surprenant justement
fabriqués qui n'est pas d'idées ah oui
encore une fois en famille il est
qualifié pour les candidats on vous le
rappelle les candidats ça va avoir lieu
c'est en espagne séquence est en
mouvement
les dates sont sortir j'ai un doute
quand je les ai publiées
mais je crois que c'est mon jour bep/j
presse et bientôt c'est dans quelques
mois donc c'est sûr que canada
doit garder quand même des idées au
chaud pour les candidats qui sont tous
importants que ce tournoi pour lui même
si ça reste un très bel événement
ça explique peut-être en partie le fait
de jouer ce double enquête aujourd'hui
stouff way
est là ok ils ne bougent pas à son sens
donc l'april a fait détruire d'autres
relèvent des trois
mais pas durer indéfiniment
comme dit alain bertal je suis assez
d'accord avec toi car les piscines et
nous fera plus de rajab of war je suis
passé radioactifs et des cariatides donc
elles sont ça marche mais j'ai des
joueurs ces dernières années beaucoup
beaucoup de futur doit sa joie merci de
confirmer beaucoup de prestations comme
ça on enchaîne les nuls
centre ont joué un et en prenant le
chèque salut à flot
hyper ambitieux de jouer sur trois
rangées au début avec les pièces
blanches
ouais mais après il va jouer avec eux
quatre et au final vous allez voir qu il
va avoir une position style attaque et
indiennes
intéressant et regarde c'est intéressant
il n'a pas joué à quatre mois il avait
plutôt à trois
mois jamais moi je préfère à trois on te
dit que tu feras b4 ici ouais parce qu'à
quatre secondes beaucoup de cases
notamment la case des cadres une fois
que je joue à cache pas j'ai du mal à
faire ces quatre jeunes tous beaucoup
trop de cases en cases noires jackass
bekaert et les vents faibles et tu à la
plage je sais 4 maintenant whissell sera
difficile à faire parce qu'il ya des
cases très faible en quatre ans et trois
cases blanches très rentable donc moi je
crois vraiment à a3 c'est plus flexible
ok bah c'est le choix de baby et
peut-être qu'on voit qu'il a joué le 4
mai sur sûr ça par contre on pourrait
plutôt jouer avec ses quatre peut-être
voile et tout possible aurait parlé de
crime en janvier 2006
donc c'est six
fois je sais tu es donc kylotonn
ont cavalé b17 ok donc là ça c'est une
position hyper intéressant d'air on l'a
vu dans le speech est ce qu'on cherche
conquis trois temps c'était nakamura qui
divise et beaucoup beaucoup système
ses pulsions exact byers et nakamura
contre eux et reconnaître qu'il soit
trop tard
c'est ça non mais c'est assez fou est en
fête
dames 2 et après il faisait beaucoup de
un moment donné il faisait souvent eu
cinq écrits et blanc et quand le
cavalier noir bouger et bien ils
mettaient la tour ou en c1 je crois
c'est assez bizarre et voulait le c4 ou
des 4 et 5 et un seul visa mais je me
demande si c'est pas
nakamura guiry je crois le match
s'est notamment adressé aux bleus
mais caruana il n'a pas joué contre moi
car un t shirt réparé du contrat
social mairie contre ce1 nakamura diéri
et il y avait beaucoup beaucoup d'eau
peut être qu'en fait du coup car il
s'est préparé sur les partis
sauf que les douves le pion au cateau
c'est la spécialité de dakar sur
internet en tant que patrie mais surtout
les libdems c'est possible donc du coup
il est nul et enfin celle de l'après pat
mac à ambühl est à 2 et du coup c'est
plus intéressant parce qu'en fait la
renommée de les blancs vont finir par
2,5 et chercher le cas ben ali qui
défend droit et en plus la case f6 est
importante parce que
c'est quelqu'un d'important une fois que
je veux cinq femmes est une grande idée
en fait pour les blancs pour attaquer
ici c'est plus tard dans le futur a joué
h4 ou qui paraît bizarre parce qu'en
fait h4 c'est là sa case age 2 est pas
quand le cavalier f3 amis c'est plutôt
pour mac le cavally et des deux ans et
freins
à cheveux et g4 en gros qui ramène
toutes les pièces sont le roi mais dans
cette pollution a très souvent le foot
ancien
bassiste chi donc là le fouet en b2 donc
c'est une remarque c'est une barre d'un
super u
voilà si le centre se faire via 1,5 le
fouillent pourra toujours peut-être se
recycler ici en fait voilà c'est ça mais
bon ça va dépendre aussi de comment
guérir jsk e s que le nom petite amie
schl arriva à créer des choses à la dame
par exemple ce que l'on va t'il à
choisir cette hyper solide mais un peu
passif
quand les blancs d'oeufs l'aise comme ça
vraiment l'opportunité
de prendre un peu le centre est où
est ce que tu peux chercher le plus avec
les noirs là il est plus dans la
solidité
et ça pourrait donc laisser du temps aux
blancs de jouer le plan convient
d'expliquer bon elle vit de trouver une
réaction est implanté ici est un cadeau
chiba trouver quoi jouer pourquoi au
fait bah en fait tu vas jeu pour ouvrir
la même foi de chacun je sens son côté
des bons jours sans leur
je pense plutôt des trucs avec à 4 des
cats et
500 kg mais pour l'instant il en a
quatre qui menace de couvrir et avoir un
truc comme ça et je pense qu'on va avoir
tout ce type de réaction d'un v6 et des
pièces qui vont arriver
une fois que la colonne s'est ouverte ce
n'est pas un retour c'est lui taper sur
ces deux
je sais pas comment ça va se jouer mais
je pense et chacun joue sur son aile
bien sûr les blancs jouent le match
donc c'est plus direct c'est ici dans un
passé encore lointain mais
ok ça ne peut développer de manière
et salue le break au corps et sticks au
salut à toi bienvenue
et bat d'ailleurs aniche ils viennent
jouer je crois qu'il a vis adamo bcsa
d'affaires la caméra ou l'accord
d'investissement public qui se placent m
et il
il prépare peut être un à quatre essais
jouer une telle info par rafah vie à
quatre
bentham états d'âme là tu vas perdre un
peu de temps et donc je joue à 80 de
fabien qui a joué à 3,4 aux deux temps
elle s'est adaptée à la configuration
des noix intéressant aussi de noter car
maintenant ici il a encore plus d'une
heure quarante à la pendule donc son
capital de départ c'est de gérer qu'il
réfléchit plus début donc on peut
supposer que le joueur américain il est
dans ses petits souliers s'il a dû
analyser cette position je pense qu'il a
je pense clairement il analysé c'est sûr
il a il a analysé le speech s naka guiry
joueurs comme michael
parfois que c'est seulement de voir que
que à ce niveau là et prépare sur un
match de blitz quoi mais du coup ça
permet d'avoir des nouvelles idées
peut-être sont tellement
ou en partie classique il faut chercher
ailleurs parfois
non mais c'est clair tous les jours ce
qui laisse tellement que grâce à porte
ses fruits ou pas je trouve ça
si on irait voir stouff alors qu'on n'a
pas encore vu 12 heures il dit
environ des lieux mais ouais en plus ils
ont joué beaucoup de coups déjà à 18 ans
seulement ouais mais c'est là c'est le
marchand qu'ils ont faim voyez c'est
bizarre c'est une grande fête
c'est
la grande classe et la pollution qu'on a
vu mille fois
oui mais c'est le même genre ça
ressemble en termes de structure vu la
position finale j'ai pas vu je la plains
créé d'emplois il ya un fond g7 à la
place ouais mais mais la corruption
c'est
bon on avait plusieurs fois
donc ça c'est la ligne d'ailleurs la
partie comme à lui c'était prague nasdaq
leblanc compris eux contre du doigt
exactement je vous le répète il est vrai
que cet échec en d4 ceux-ci
b4u prendre un procès normal l avc / g
il y avait la partie de aussi de mort et
10 contres l'aja la george mason
je pensais qu'il y avait le tour on
vient en fait un grand péché b 4 échecs
c'était notre idée c'est celle que
j'avais en tête au hockey ouais mais
emprunt qu'il avait joué avec toro un
tour bien plus mauvais les besoins tour
aux trois tours deux proches président
tu sais si c'est vrai
ou d'opter avantage blanc parce que
manger le centre mais après le noir sont
hyper solide et puis mais c'est bien sûr
c'est dur de se désespérer vous pour le
garer devant par contre je pense à
lui je vous solide être un peu de voir
ce qui se passe est ponctuée en contre
j'attends mes styles dont jouissent les
banques ont rien
pu faire contre eux ouais c'est ça
autant le style de
position tranchées comme ça ça horizons
il est bien placé ouais là ont d'abord
il ya la solution qui nous demandent
stouff si dans ma grande fête c'est de
mauvais de fer s'est rendu aussitôt
le jeu penche pas comprendre car je ne
supporte que caen avant que chalmé moi
donc de toute façon au moins un jeu
relativement vite comment décathlon à
une semble aussi sec c'est calme il a
pas de partie de bac 6 mai donnez moi
ouais mais là c'est pas une simple et là
c'est pas une c'est pas une folie si
la spa grâce à lucien la grande scène en
fait une croix sur la même position sauf
que le fou noir se ranger 7 et le pion
eux si ce serait un ancêtre
c'est ça
je pense que tu peux aller un peu plus
loin la du genre avant tout b4 par
exemple
un peu la nuance
ici le pub le foot rend g7 et le pion au
noir ce qu'on veut c'est ça ce serait
une ça ce serait une
bonne nouvelle un peu plus la france 5
et c'est vrai
mais vous les champs j'arrive quand même
que tu peux montrer de l'ordre de coups
de la bonne file des bus tu veux bien
montré
donc c'est g6 là oui parce que le jouer
si je réalise les trois quarts de ces
trois ans que je ne change pas de 17 au
dessin de suite et 5 décembre
2004 et fois plus cher qu'un de
ses fils ont vraiment la jeunesse est
oui c'est presque elle va les prendre 2
la c5 g7 donc cette assemblée de neuf
jouer ouais mais je sais pas grand
qu'est la nuance entre les deux offres
légales mais quand on aura il y avait
des f-35 ça c'est la jeune femme
c'est exact
c'est le fouquet l'appelation vraiment
pas du coup on regarde les fous de cases
noires dans cette recette ouverture
pour revenir
à ce qui s'est vraiment passé dans la
partie ils font disparu
donc c'est une partie qui va être très
[Musique]
très lente c'est plein de choses
et mais bon pour l'instant je pense
qu'on va pas les mettre de côté voire un
peu à la fin ce qui se passe parce que
bon c'est pas sincèrement je pense
oui
olala 10 pour alice du coup puisque tu
nous parles caisse fédérale 3 la qualif
comment tu as
des 24 heures de forme d'options va
peut-être se placer des fois un petit
peu vers le roi qui s'est
s'est pas encore des petits détails
parfois le fou brassens et paraissait
pas si facile mais
je vois bien qu'ils tour des deux gros
gain est poussé un des cinq lois qui
gardent les vl vie dit
oui
est ce qu'on peut est ce que tu penses
comme avant mais comme tour des trois
fours j'ai trois jeunes aiment interrogé
est ce qu'on va voir g4 c'est quoi la
petite tournoi je ne pense pas parce que
le pion une la malle arrière glissant
pour l'instant mais quelle
bonne idée pour remettre la station sur
ce roi qui n'a pas tendre des penseurs
que sa part le cavalier voit pas donc le
sien vis-à-vis avec la dame h4 sur le
cavalier est aussi sur la tour sete des
fois il peut se passer des choses le
fougueux trois kits actions auront aussi
c'est un joueur en qui dé 5,2
intéressant ok on ne chante pas ça reste
solide et les mélanges les blancs devant
une petite pression assez gratuitement
complet tout le monde donc visite vous
rappelle qu'elle idée lauda qui pourrait
aussi être en tête mais cas
malheureusement pour lui éviter des fins
de partie un peu difficile a contaminé
at il été gameiro il a fini par la
perdre hier donc il aurait raté un
regain de la répétition de coûts fait
qu'il à la moyenne pour l'instant le
joueur polonais alors que vu le contenu
il pourrait être plus haut avant
aujourd'hui il arrive à résister
aux assauts de vie en tout cas il s'en
laisse pas conter il prend sa chance à
la dame il envoie b5 on peut supposer
que l'emploi va suivre
paraît logique arcelormittal de contrat
mais du coup là on voit le coût de
l'ordinateur que c'est assez logique
avec cavalli des trois quarts a laissé
cinq dans l'idée d'essayer de
récupérer la case vu que voilà
l'inconvénient de bessengue c'est la
casse 500 euros
et la broue fait on
trop vite
est ce parce que
subissent
ces pratiques
terrible
cette centrale
qui avait des 17 langues a été cette
fois ci pour recettes
alors que
[Musique]
le parti il ya une partie que j'aime
bien je sais qu'on n'a pas encore vu
on apprend on du
mamediarov n'est pas encore en vue du
golfe mais bon ces deux partis se passe
pas grand chose pour l'instant est-ce
qu'on n'irait pas voir chant clan
printemps parce que la partie allait
entrer très mouvementée à l'aller et
franchement
se faire plaisir retournez voir dans une
poule à
je crois que vous envoyez le lien de la
partie je vais rouler à kevin quoi
voulez faire peur pour aller en tout cas
s'ils regardent ou la une à une pulsion
hyper intéressante je viens de nous
alerter sous forme souvent la caméra la
caméra volante qui est sûr ça me choque
lourde qui est bien concentré alors
on avait cette ouverture et cette
position sur ce je vous rappelle que
quand on était là
prague le prodige a il avait envoyé en
bessin il avait sacrifié
en disant tant pis adoption passagers
sur le long terme et moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est d'avoir un jeu
dynamique et d'ailleurs comme on l'avait
dit la rocqué parce que ce rachat
maintenant on ne peut plus manger le
faux de est vouée à la défense du
cavaliere
a quatre souffre par ailleurs anticiper
mais ça ne dépend pas vraiment le cheval
qui doit toujours
garder c'est des fous rires à cause du
boulot à qui il a fait le coup très
osées f5 en fait mais ça me fait penser
à des parties de carlson cerveau avec
les norias pas in en sommes librement il
n'avait pas exactement ça mais
personne n'a ri car seul un jeu la chef
nicholas rythmique heures pendant
longtemps de ses sculptures il les a eus
à jouer des choses comme ça ou hyper
d'hellemmes sacrifier les plus riches
contre
42 l'occupation non je me suis un
panneau sacrifiant des 5 mai
mais ça ça m'est vraiment familier donc
cette position à double tranchant hyper
chaude alors il a pris part au vote dont
on prend à chaque partie mais
contrairement à ce qu'on vient de dire
il gagne à voir est ce donc le cavalier
je touche n'est plus défendu c'est ça
qui fait que même si on peut encaisser
en v5
bas on des changements question g6
ailleurs si la partie sur ma partie des
cinq ou six ans juste pour montrer qu'on
peut vraiment pas manger ici parce que
tombent
les villages toutes les pièces c'est le
jackpot dont il a pris la
dvi tête et jouer avec la petite menace
insidieuse
de gagner la dame
donc j'imagine qu'elle a bougé saddam
shankland la fed à bout des trois
échecs
s'il a choisi de mettre le fou de van
den broeck est intéressant
c'est la vôtre et très chaud et damas
est joué par crackdown d'alors d'abbas
est
pour le coup maintenant le fou est
prenable mais attention au psoas the way
et après dans progression d'un point l2
déjà on ne pourrait pas faire roi des
huns à cause d'un f3 échec pour
encaisser la tourache ans il a progressé
sur la première rangée y aurait plein de
perpétuels il y aura aussi une idée ait
un projet 3 et celle d'un projet 6 si tu
venais mettre ton à spa troisième rangée
et sur dame e2 bas à voir ce qui se
passe c'est pas du tout je vois qu'il ya
une belle
on peut faire caler un ballon fait un
tour b vitesse à laquelle on veut
peut-être celle-ci wii prend b2 lda
parce qu'on peut pas revenir ici pour
défendre le pion à cause de l'enfilade
ouais si on va être là c'est pareil on a
mangé b2 et là bas ce roi
admettons qu'on gagne on peut hein pour
essayer de s'accrocher comme des
catalyseurs à damas son comble que
simple
partie intéressante mais on voit que les
deux joueurs ont l'air dans leur pré pas
plus ou moins parce que j'ai encore les
blancs alors en d2 et à 1h40 à la
pendule c'est vrai alors que prône la
honda il à 1h15 mais bon il pousse loin
d égaler damas elle sacrifie le fou
peut-être qui connaît un qu'il devait se
rappeler petit à petit ses idées il faut
répondre aussi à jadis
par rapport à la poussée exxon qui court
derrière
en fait ici oui douar il doit comme on
l'a dit chercher du jeu avec les doigts
il a sacrifié
il a sacrifié un pion qui doit s'activer
reid doit créer des doit créer des
thèmes l'objet de jeunes d'ailleurs en
fait concrète et agressive on ne peut
pas il peut pas faire des coudes
attendent surtout de cette chaise sont
là dessus pour bien placé ou s'il envoie
ses pions ici
et donc entendez là
et attend l'appel pour donner ici et ici
donc championnes qui réfléchit
évidemment il est pas obligé de manger
ce couac sip faire d'autre et ce qu'est
ce qui se passe sur un coup keller assez
logique pour justement c'est de
la fatigue atx la tête à la terre avec
beaucoup de signes
étaient d'accord avec nous a dit avec
tout ce qu'on a dit
ça lui mypower salut à toi à moi ça va
un peu mieux c'est un peu merci de merci
de demander j'ai encore un petit peu de
tout mais
mais ça va ça va médicaments et jeu je
me soigne
et donc d'armes le 3 nov qu'est ce qu'on
ferait ici on n'a pas envie de changer
les dames j'imagine plonger bien loin
donc je gardais pierre robin bell
sera pour moi j'ai un peu moins et puis
même toit fin non mais
je pense qu'ici elle arrivera en d2 il
est hors de question que messieurs dames
1 je peux le regarder
est ce qu'on voit là un échec
perpétuelle réflexion de groupe ares
dont points et si ce qu'il voudra masse
est maintenant est ce parce que ça veut
dire et un an à 7 pour les six hommes et
six ans
je ne sais pas qui est la différence
admettons qu'il peut y avoir de
répétition comme ça
ce serait bien de voir où mais est-ce
que champion vraiment voire nuls comme
ça dès le début avec les blancs contre
le joueur qui est le moins fin tellement
jalouse et pour moi le papier
il a toujours pas joué chez d'actualité
de condé comme ça qu'est ce qui peut
faire à part d'un de trois doigts des
formes champion f2
run tôt
et si federer 3 vous essayez de
contre-attaqué menée 4-1 et adam des
captifs et très mal
fait il faut contrôler la cage des
canaris ont peut pas espérer que l'on
sert il ya une tour qui viendrait nous
mater et sur var var cela s'est terminé
n'a pas le temps parce que vous pouvez
être fier de contre attaquer on n'a pas
du tout le temps
d'ailleurs bateau
mais de toute façon on doit tous faire
manger et le roi ou pire des cas même
s'il n'est pas tant d'échecs pourrait
fuir
donc les blancs doivent pas essayer de
contre-attaqué de profiter de ce fou
quand même
bien placé pour créer des réseaux de
batte
ou est ce qui va vraiment avoir le choix
si champions peut-être c'est juste et ne
sais pas il n'y a pas
clin d'oeil avec les blancs
en tout cas il est quand même assez
assez fort et assez pro pour le
comprendre et pour accepter de faire nul
si c'est le cas
même s'il est favori sur le papier qui
se prend une préparation c'était s'ils
pensent que c'est dangereux il va
prendre la mesure
et du coup je pense que là nul c'est un
résultat qui enfin en tout cas là une
reddition c'est un acquis clairement
assez probable on sait pollution n'aura
pas s'il se trouve une autre idée mais
c'est vrai que ça paraît pas vraiment
être un pro c'est l'argent et donc
si prendre à regarder d'armes enfants
est ce que ça change vraiment quelque
chose
d'un problème de ça va encore mal se
passer ce qui n'a pas la dame qui peut
revenir
c'était de le voir l'avancée voir
atterrir dans la colonne de
l'aco lancée et c'était suroît bien que
le gamin je prends la tour
pas pardon
ça me fait rire aussi
fatigués
il
est vrai ne vois pas d'autre option que
de que de concéder la répétition de
couleurs après est ce que est ce que
prague lui peut
ne pas vouloir répéter les propos
comment bond intéressant on va voir du
coup on va peut-être changer la question
dans le chat ça a été répondu
charles à gmail
du coup je n'ai pas encore vu du bab et
diarra
mamediarov armée médias qui se passe pas
grand chose à voir ok c'est quoi
ici beaucoup non plus pas ce fameux
grand chose mais on peut aller voir ce
qui se passe quand même j'espère que
vous voyez un peu les positions ouvertes
et après on ira voir onze après on ira
voir jean marc andrieu
qui est encore dans le parti reçu ouais
alors on va me dire à pelletier en tête
ex-aequo avec sa porte il dit après sa
victoire d'hier avec les pièces noires
courtes robes en forêt ce double rendez
vous qui a pu retrouver un petit peu de
confiance en seront la nuit contre car
c'est lui qui reste dernier du tournoi
on m'avait dit en favori en
fonctionnement dans cette partie
a choisi une anglaise donc plutôt une
approche à 7 francs qu'ils
n'hésitent pas avoir été si tu as une
aide sur
théorique à nous apporter à tout moment
alors vous aussi c'est un coup au kaki
et nous ferait quoi je moi je je je
connais pas ok
j'ai déjà vu ce genre de truc arriver
enfin dans les parties mais je ne sais
pas je peux pas te dire ok ok en fait on
peut se permettre de bloquer ici parce
qu'apparemment dans cette danse est
variable on sait que le faux va sûrement
s'échanger et donc on pourra comme
libéré notre foot cases noires de la
sorte c'est ce qui s'est passé l'idée
aussi en fait je pense a en effet essayé
de forcer peut-être un
renard dépensé 4
est donc là il retrouve coincé ses
descendantes réservé dans l'idée mais on
se dit est vrai ouais mais je ne sais
pas du tout un jeu celle ci s'était joué
il est attendu j'ai 6 novembre
casser la structure évidemment ok donc
effectivement nous l'avait annoncé il ne
se passe pas grand chose pour l'instant
mais c'est intéressant quand même de
voir que les blancs sont attendus g6
pour manger f6 parce que maintenant les
normes temps du game
6 teintes rouges sur g7 bon par contre
d'autres où ça me
on va sûrement le comble et du
g7
mais du coup
le fou g7 ben en fait
la sata on va libérer oui bien sûr mais
ce faux pas pas si sûr de vouloir
vraiment le frange et 7,5 voulez bien
je mets tout lui va aussi en b 4e des 6
bat b 4,6 g propre à arrêter 6 mai donc
c'est pas si sûr en plus comme le lait
comme comme les les blancs et échanger
leur foute cases noires
leroy et
[Musique]
-2 4 n'est pas là
donc je suis patient de vraiment mettre
le franc g7 en tout cas
de laisser en six sets mais après dans
le doute sur ce que tu vas faire
actualisation un peu bizarre moi c'est
que je fais comme je suis comme coco
l'asticot ça me fait toujours bizarre de
voir ce souvenir devant le pion comme ça
je le garde gratuit type c mais bon ici
que l'instance doit faire part c'est
sympa
et c'est il ya des raisons concrètes qui
ont du sens mais ok on va attendre du
coup puisque cette partie voyait pas
très avancé pour l'instant on va la
laisser évoluer pour voir s'il se passe
des choses plus à libé
devrait donc avoir le duel russo russes
entrent tout boeuf et espère qu après
s'expliquer a ajouté un truc par rapport
à la partie juste devant des lieux tu as
refusé cette frappe est un fait pas ça
fait pas mal penser à la structure une
sorte de
profs ski cd4 des quatre cavaliers qui
se fout gesac wii ou en fait qui à frire
souvent il faut point m6 et défense
progressiste serpent aux mille fois et
juste si tu remets au début inscriptions
débutent la partie
au tout début ouais genre mais mais dès
4h à ce que vous n'avez pas moins de
passage à ce point comme changer le 1er
mai on va faire avec la bvm6 des 4 g 6
ou g5 et on va jouer des 5 juste pour
voir pouvoir il faut prendre comprendre
est en fait très souvent dans ces
conditions là est bien le foot à 15 ans
un des six
il va pas angers 7 parce que ben y'a pas
besoin de défendre un cadre noir parce
que le foot et asmar des blancs est
parti et les foules et 7 serait un peu
inefficace parce qu'en fait à près de 3
mètres et souvent les blancs plus tard
ils vont en jeu 3 et vont vraiment avoir
le pion le pion des cas très solide et
la police est il du mal à a vraiment à
quel point est d'ailleurs un noir avec
ses cinq soirées pas forcément très bon
parce que après on pourra voir un
premier volet en d5 et donc du coup
c'est que fouleront en d6 et
généralement on tape tôt soit hd et donc
elle est partie comme santa cruz et
du coup le fou g7 ce n'est pas forcément
très très bien placé vous savez c'est un
petit peu à ça
au niveau de la structure
[Musique]
c'est qu'un pion c4 il n'y a pas de
plongeurs de troyes
où je réfléchissais je me disais
peut-être dans celle l'un par rapport à
l'autre que je connais
un jour avec le foot à pêche pour d4
c'est ça et
et donc du coup là c'est pour ça que je
te demande en marche parce que
normalement bon après
dans la balle dans le trou boxe qu'il ya
un clown ans à sète et du coup je sais
si on le solide et le centre il est ok
là on a un pion isolant un des cinq on
va un jour essayer de manger en c4 ou
avortement le pion isoler nos rangs des
4 et le taper et donc voilà après je
sais pas à quel point vraiment
efficace mais en tout cas petite nuance
intéressante en tout cas on va voir du
coup ce que choisit grand déluge
réfléchi dispose sûrement cette question
et à laquelle diagonale à partir à nous
faut là je pense qu'il ya savoir quand
même parce que s'ils jouent faux 6
heures
on imagine les brevets y réfléchit donc
mais peut-être que les deux aussi sont
jouables en fait est que ça donne des
types de position différentes qui vont
scier plus ou moins style wado tu sais
aussi à prendre en compte parfois c'est
pas parce que vous n'êtes pas choisi
qu'il est mauvais c'est juste que le
joueur est plus être dans un autre genre
de position
là les deux options ne sommes pas
stupides en tout cas
mais bon s'ils mettent leur jet set
c'est bien là bas si tu mettre au fond
des six effectivement il ya des choses
que le roi vient d'enlever cette
pourrait peut-être
les trous très plutôt plutôt petit rock
et après tu auras pourquoi 17 mai ma
part
voilà il ya d'autres il yad'autres sera
pas la priorité des changes
alors ça me je sais que on n'a pas fini
de faire le tour des partis mais est-ce
qu'on partie répandre en cause
je sais que caisse comme est assez peu
quand même juste conclure on n'est pas à
deux minutes près bien sûr on voit du
beau fessier l'événement aura tout fait
et après on viendra après la pause avec
un maori dit alors on revient vite donc
il ya encore une cavalière foi qui est
plutôt à la mode d'aujourd'hui
homme sirote tranquillement fait son
truc dans son coin et on transpose de
nouveau derrière
noah donc ça c'est pas mal qui vient
lutter contre son visage de la grande
diagonale d'alex qui est marrant c'est
dans cette partie sont aux mains de
support en arrière à van damme à quatre
voies
il ya le coût qui existent cavale et a3
qui intéressant pour les jo avec
lecavalier et away
n'importe quoi c'est ces dames d'hommes
ces deux d'abord je crois ok et qu'elle
valait 17 cavaliers à trois
et il faut prendre à trois qui a été
jouée par mathieu cornette avec les
blancs et avec et noir se tarissent
et les cadets b 6
avec noah roquettes grad et le pion
[Musique]
et donc c'est un peu 526 pas eu la
partie qu'on avait vu de karachi c'est
notre
guiry en début de tournoi où cardona
gagner oui on voit qu'il est de
l'intérêt la france pendant et après la
russie reprendra la plaine des jeux à 4
x 3 est à voir jusqu'au 15 mars
est facile à guérir
et moi à l'époque où je jouais landaise
romantique
et ben j'avais bien vu que cavalia 3d
mais j'ai mes yeux et je l'avais travail
et
[Musique]
donc de mai après damas cats est le coup
le plus simple est mais aussi d'un
procès quatre des cinq merci qu'on gagne
un temps sur la dame aux mille francs
bessette et ses positions sont très très
dur à vraiment prendre l'avantagé clé
blanc
donc c'est un juste une information
c'est que l'on voit que doivent quand
même il a une heure 43 contre 52 minutes
évidemment une différence de
connaissances ici dans cette danse est
parti et si bien qu avec les plus jeunes
qui a peut-être important qu'au moins
solides comme g derrière fléchir un peu
à chaque coup et du bois fear is it
alors qu'eric emmaüs qui n'a pas peur
des changes et d'échanger les fous il va
jouer sur 15 mois dans mon avis hein
donc à des changes je crée des petites
pressions sur la case voire peut-être
autour du roi moi je viens [ __ ] b8 des
m17
comprendre les cases blanches ouais
prend la casse des cinq et quinze en
fait pour les quatre centrales à damer
le pion à cavaillon 17 ans juste ouf
qu'est ce qui se passe sur m6 quand même
si j'aime à ok
bah oui
pour résoudre le problème je l'avais
dire qu'elle allait prendre cette tempo
mais en fait j'avais le tripitaka dame
cavaliers cesse il semblerait forcé pour
pas perdre de mater donc j'imagine qu'à
venir ici qu'on doit calculer
way pour le reste du temps des prix sur
quatre nouvelles lignes pour
aller quel tour c'est pas si claire
celle ci pour ses sacs ça fait penser à
une partie de guiry aux candidats
avec les blancs et c'est simple
peut-être
[Musique]
à voir ce que risque avaler prendre b4
voir ou est ouest couloir 3 tons
cavaliers parce que
l'idée en fait c'est que ton cavaliers
il est vraiment mal placé genre liferay
siphonnant 17 s'est battu vautours des
six lots tour en ligue 1 je fais c'est
dense y a
j'ai quasiment à propulsion ou la
structure sa marge même plus passer
c'est clair que ça
final du tour il ya de l'activité
les boxeurs ça me tendant fait la reine
il ya peut-être pression blanche c'est
ce qui est intéressant c'est que tout ça
c'est hyper port sans bon vu la vitesse
à laquelle joue du bois doit connaître
justement arrivé à savoir qu'ici la
petite pression que les noirs doivent
être précis et certainement que si bien
qu ils calculent ça parce que s il veut
il peut rentrer de manière forcée dans
cette fille-là
weepu voyaient déjà beau jeu là les
choper à dieu
salut marieuse château ouais salut à toi
watch d'accord avec avec michel sniper
ça me semble quand même le hockey pour
les noirs même c'est sûr qu'elle est
petite idée de double
vue lcd super ok quand même hyper solide
qu'elle a bien d'obtenir les duels dans
les positions un peu en arrière je
serais pas surpris
qu'il rentre là dedans écoute je te
propose de découvrir sa après la petite
pub est ce que tu voulais parler moi ma
femme vient d'abord si tu veux voir où
je voulais le voir après on va les voir
avant
ça on aura fait un tour complet
marc-andré ya donc vous le rappelle sa
droite est divisée pour l'instant il a
un demi point sur ce qu on espère qu'il
va cependant c'est que les pièces
bourges contre l'expérimenté grand
maître joue à domicile un airois de
l'ami erwin pardon héroïne lamy
alors
on a une mise au
pas pas du tout mon répertoire donc si
tu connais bien mais faut des deux
non je ne peux pas non plus mais
pas trop d'intérêt c'est de mettre le
fournisseur parce que la diagonale est
fermé même si on regrettera par contre
vous il est rayonnant dans cette démo
n'a donc on va être très heureux de les
changer l'important ici pour les d'orge
et après même des fois le football ce
type il peut être intéressant de jouer
avec ses singles sur émettre un cavalier
en 1 4
mais oui fois ci ces thématiques 1,07 le
fou du roi c'est le bon fout des blancs
donc on veut bien sûr le frangin
et salue le chat n'est qu'un
j'ai vu tes beaux progrès sur tous comme
le chan est
peut-être là commença dans le futur à
venir
les snipers qui nous dit c'est bizarre
xiping cours et autant de retard à la
pointure bas certainement que oui d'oiry
doit être ça quelque peu familier de la
position mais d'avoir beaucoup moins
d'expérience que je boive dedans et il
est obligé de prendre du temps pour se
rappelèrent c'est à petit
on va voir si ça lui coûte quelque chose
ou non et pour conclure avec cette
partie de marc andrieu emballé par ce
qui s'est passé il avait changé les fous
stouff way back a été jouée une galerie
et rentrer au bercail
et ma foi d'une position tout à fait
jouable avec peut-être une légère
pression blanche laquelle se focalisent
plutôt bien placé car est le blanc des
blancs d'après toi ici dans cette
position justement je me pose la
question est ce qu'on va pas déjà être
si d'aller manger ce que je me demandais
avec un cavalier de saint ghislain
roubaix 4 ou entourent siens mais bon on
va chercher les pièces avec ses 5 quand
il ya 15 4 way faire attention à ça
aussi
ça ne semble pas évident j'ai pas
l'impression que ce soit forcément un
succès pour les bleus
va être en tous cas doit être être un
plan et vous isolez 3 et le 4 mai
parce que je vois pas trop comment
entretenir le flou à part ça et c'est
difficile de jouer l'état
pressé de voir la gold
cup
mais le tour sur le clown ouverte c'est
quand même pour ses masques m
nikolov 20% sera normal aussi et après
74 ces deux jeux vraiment sur un char
les colonies weert bel sais pas si
c'est parce que là
on va voir comment notre petit prodige
français s'en sortent et l'a
certainement une idée même si on voit
qu'il a déjà pas mal réfléchi dans cette
position jusque là eu du mal dans les
ouvertures ouais donc la réponse dans
les minutes à venir quoi qu'il est temps
de faire notre première pause stouff y s
est dit je suis très bien donc quelques
minutes il est simple et claire magnus
qu'un celle dont on va voir où il en est
[Musique]
et
oh
[Musique]
on
m
[Musique]
nous sommes de retour souffre et j'ai
pas ni tout de suite la partie de
baghlan fait elle a peu évolué par
contre on avait laissé shankland et
prague d'ananda sur le point de répéter
les cours
commencent à répéter un premier ep
station a exactement étaient là c'est
qu'il nous rejoigne on avait cette
position
hypercomplexes l' hyper intéressante où
le petit prodige du rap venait de jouer
d'abbas est pour menacer le prime 2 et
potentiellement sacrifia sion fou on
avait vu que si jamais le joueur
américain était trop gourmand d'aller se
faire battait avec son roi qui allait
échouer dans une colonne
ou une tour à l'arrivée ils auraient été
des problèmes de partout il y avait tout
rebelle est d'ailleurs le plus précis un
stock on avait dit même que ses robes et
8 d'abord ici
yade à la dame qui devait bouger et
derrière
les pions b2f de qui tombe et s'est
terminée à une attaque décisive
et comme on s'y attendait
vih-sida me3 été joué pour défendre le
pion ont proposé d'échanger dernière
évidemment été refusée par un jardin
stuff ouais donc dans les cinq échecs on
avait dit on a là on a deux pions de
voir en elle attaque le roi beaublanc et
en d2 dont knapp que sur aucune envie de
chanter l'équipe dams et 3 ans couvre
les chèques et d'abaisser ses envies
dire le retour même s'il n'est pas allé
sur exactement la même case l'idée est
la même une table sur le pion f2 et
c'est vrai que naturellement son
meilleur des six comme à sète parce que
l'on libère ce vis-à-vis et la tablette
peut parfois rares d'elle sur le cube et
de souffrance et gervinho
donc là on s'attend probablement avoir
une répétition une dame trois dames à 5
et d'un v6 et un nul qui serait donc
un bon résultat pour pardon avec edward
bond est clairement battu une mule sans
jouer on fait ça on appelle on m'appelle
faire une nul à la maison c'est ça parce
qu'on doit te donne tu as travaillé
cette ligne à la maison et du coup
vincent et béchir sent quasiment
réfléchir dans la partie d'échecs là
aujourd'hui eh bien il a réussi à faire
mieux avec par action qu'il a fait c'est
ça on vu chez lui il a déjà fait 7 voir
dans son cahier il avait la barre
jusqu'au bout c'était marqué ça se
termine par une nulle part échec
répétition du coup et c'est exactement
ce qu en train de se passer donc voilà
donc du coup c'est vraiment très très
bien de la part de prendre avant demain
que les noirs contre je ferme champions
en 2007 tandis quand même surtout qu'il
a perdu hier depuis doublé les noirs ce
n'est pas facile hague ça serait à 19h
stopper l'hémorragie championne qui
réfléchit à voir est ce qu il a
une façon de refuser l'adul a priori
ensemble on allait regarder on n'a pas
trop mais on n'a pas trouvé mépris des
fonctions il n'y a pas de tourner il
peut venir alors un coup tiens on n'a
pas regardé comme tout rage 2 pour
défendre le sont ouais mais aussi le
culte je voyais le message tant
qu'émetteur de
datacert qui ne dit que je serais
parfait aujourd'hui bercy jean fait un
lapsus d'émotion
prague avec les blancs contre chant
ample en faire une zone qui a qui ramène
direct annuler sort est un peu un peu
décevant quand même parce qu'il paraît
que blanc tu vas quand même si loin un
peu pour les avantages mais faire une
prépa pour un nul avec les noirs c'est
que c'est quand même tout à son honneur
et c'est un très très bon résultats
bondir
vouloir juste un surcoût comme 3 2 et
par intuit sinon j'ai pas ce que vous en
pensez dans le chat qui nous regardent
si le 5 août devant visuel et votre tour
le cantonais un cours de l'échiquier
vous avez certes un tour de plus avec
les blancs nous voyais à toutes les
pièces qui vont arriver sur ce seront en
blanc qui a perdu au milieu de
l'échiquier ça va très mal se passer
vous n'avez pas aux coups à tour âge que
pour défendre ce qui fait que encore une
fois la seule solution a priori c'est ce
fameux 3 d'ailleurs parce que les
joueurs sont pas en train de répéter
et réfléchit toujours un champ clos
va revenir peut-être bat pour la lula a
priori l'officialisation de l'a2 dans
quelques instants et on va aller voir un
d'autres échiquier salut arabe et à ce
qu'on pourrait aller voir
vie dit duda parce que ça assez content
que 8 a vraiment tous les plans que je
que su proposer
avec un petit plus blanc
gérer avec lui ou que après b5 on avait
une idée de lecavalier détroit pour le
cavalier simple profiter de la casse et
5 exact mais j'avais aussi l'idée de
retourner trois tours de 3 pour attaquer
le roi m amuse avis et taper taper sur
les cases noires et tu veux ma tei ci
est visitée d'accord avec lui
tu veux comme je touche alors je sais
pas si c'est une bonne nouvelle ou pas
normalement son accueil leader du tour
doit donc faut croire que oui on est en
tout cas d'arrêté moi j'ai pas très
impressionné par tourner des voyages et
envois de content ici et je vais essayer
de déstabiliser kung fu se fout qu'il a
peut-être devoir oculaires ou en des
erreurs selon ce qui se passe c'est ça
non plus le tour j'ai 3 et surtout rejet
trois cavaliers points et 4,1 live qu'on
nous explique pas ce que semble qu'on
perd quand même du matériel ok alors ça
devient intéressant bon alors justin
confère la porte ont menacé de gagner le
cavalier part d'un problème 6 grâce au
cloud a comme ça c'était une très grosse
menace et si le roi juste bouger tout
moi je pense qu'ils y habitent et qui
est sympathique est-ce qu'elles marchent
pas mon avis oui
c'est tout reprend g7 c'est quelque
chose qui par notre oeil qui a envie de
s'engouffrer dedans de sacrifier la tour
pour casser le bouclier des noirs verts
ont fait échec au roi va bouger et on va
récupérer
beaucoup de villes en dépendent a mangé
un cavalier un pion pour la tour mais
surtout on a prouvé complètement notre
adversaire sur cases noires
et là où nasri bat déjà le roi quand
même pas ces chapelles romanes du
couloir
et si le roi essaie de combler on va
simplement ramener la deuxième tour pour
porter l'estocade et sesat 1 bat
imparable à suivre donc ça c'est
vraiment thématiques ici les noirs comme
on l'avait d'ailleurs annoncé alice -
peut faire sur cases noires
et attention tu reprends jet set c'était
une grosse menace donc il y avait tout
ranger cette aide 1.966 hier
et ça explique peut-être pourquoi il ya
eu 84
4 tours prend au cap donc là il va de
pièces pour la tour mais manger un bon
centre à
comprendre travers priva pas à 4 qui va
aussi au bitume en fous d'allah en d1
ouais c'est très intéressant ce choix de
verdun petit déséquilibre d'un point de
vue matériel la position
[Musique]
et ce rapport fou cavaliers contre tours
piot en général on essaie plutôt bien
pour les deux pièces
mais ici là quand même un certain contre
jeu qui est lié à cette option qui sont
dangereux ouais et une petite faiblesse
mais aussi de la première rangée du fait
que la peau hâlée déserté
ya encore eu des courses tokyo et si si
si
des loges le seul puis son cavalier qui
revient au détroit
et enfin mandela duda a joué dam des six
parties bilan déjà dit qu'ils tuent
prévert dans cette position et pourquoi
on marque par leblanc matériellement je
t'aime
de pièces en terme de points va dire que
c'est si on s'en tire notamment d'asie
pour moi
mais le prg est un jeune allemand de
pièces après la fusion des quatre qui
peuvent couper de l'est avec un tour
pour des scènes notamment qui pourrait
arriver sur des quatre prix est aussi la
commune s'est cassé mon cas il ya ça
vous produit là pour les noirs vraiment
le plan des cas et il ya aussi le projet
serait le deux contre un à l'aide
d'armes
et aussi haletant que les trois qui
c'est ma classe et maintenance à la tour
et rentrer plus grand chose voyez que la
taxe va être nul en prenant et blanc ont
besoin de ce
genre organisée dans la pièce l'heure
mais notre manque d'harmonie ici
maintenant
et j'aimerais beaucoup faire bouger un
peu mes pièces cavaliers les organiser
ou derrière il a paraphé coin de calme
et un coup comme kara et ses sacs se
heurterait à toute concession avec un
vis-à-vis et
et des compétences et pas vraiment
comment placer cette pièce donc c'est
vraiment intéressant en terme de
pratique ce qu'a fait sa pub
il a résolu ses problèmes en tout cas
datta khel comme on vient de vous
montrer il y avait des examens gros
déroger à exito projet celle d'une dame
problème c'est sur ce roi il a
complètement changé la donne et les
enjeux de la position par c'est par cet
échange et libre
et
et j'écris pays ces cinq avaient été
gelés
j'ai l'impression qu'ils et c'est ça qui
a été jouée stuff je vois sur
l'échiquier cavaliers c5 a été joué
ok cette passe mal dans les idées
qu'elle dort amplement notre réponse
c'est ça
un peu un peu choqué par le coup de deux
villes dj l'attendait pas ce canal j c
50 on veut
peut-être qu'en fait il est à considérer
avec des mots problème équivalent et qui
venait lui vaut en rire la pendule
qu'à 38 milliards oui
j'aime à l'automne
la seat en date en france et 5 pensent
que dubai la nation d'investir votre
banque ou échec 3 à cheveux et là du
coup en bas un processus qui est passé
bien qu on les noirs et un peu plus un
port de droit qui peut arriver mais y en
plus pas avoir comme aimant
l'intéressant choix si on pourra noter
ouais c'est sûrement parce que dans
lequel ben talal ben avance et
ne leur en quoi et qu'est ce qui se
passe à voir ou comme dame d'afrique
moi je ne rêve des changes les là avec
les draps bien sûr mais j'ai rapidement
plus je vais clairement essai de jeu
pour le gars ici dont a priori
il doit garder les dab beyrouth ap des
softs paraît quand même un coût très
naturelle du gain dans une attaque à
deux tu attaques c'est simple tu des
volontés centralise
sam cooke qui me semble très prometteur
pour les noirs maintenant des cinq
six ou neuf en baisse d'un point b sans
hockey et peut-être statistiques du coup
part et les deux
je défends j'évite l'échec c'est 3
celui de vierzy changer la donne je dis
que nomade sur b4 abu sitta 1er
mai mais bon en pratique si son jeu je
préfère un noir a maintenant gagné
à bord ici avec l'arbre et salut salut
fils savais plus ce que
je veux et c'est vrai qu'ici opus
un choix très osé alors en visite qui
est en tête qui n'a pas perdu deux
parties jusque là attention avec les
blanche
émaillée c5
matériel voilà de quoi il a eu peur ils
n'auraient plus juste mais c'est de
bouger surtout mal et c'est vrai que ces
pièces sont bien passées il a pas de
bonnes cartes pour son foie quand même
faut bouger pour se donner la ccl 620 en
fait il ya un tour qui rend l'adoption
bonne faire très peur cette course est
donc si jamais je me replonge de cela
peut faire rentrer de peur
vraiment
une belle promotion pour la danse est
pour qu elle même placée y ait cette
désorganisation aux fêtes s'est dit ok
mes pièces sont n'y a pas d'harmonie
retrait du coup je vais rendre le
matériel
mais ils vont le matin avec intérêt ce
qui lui avoir un fondement duda qui doit
calculer tout ça mais bronze et or il
n'ya pas de monde dans lequel ils ne
mangent pas ces cinq injuste inefficace
qui veut jouer ensuite
bah on à michel qui nous dit que il
reprend confiance en les blogs ou
intéressement
pourquoi donc de plus honnêtement
je trouve que dame des cinq ici quand
même assez part
on va voir petite piécette sur le joueur
polonais après duda comme on l'a dit
plus tôt dans le stream il a
gâché des occasions lors des dernières
partir il a fait un demi sur deux heures
on est en gagnant les deux fois elle a
encore une position prometteuse à voir
ce qu'ils ont fait facteur intéressant
il a plus d'une heure vingt à la pendule
contre 38 minutes normalement il a tout
le temps du monde pourra
en profiter
ou à l'autre n'ont pas avoir grandi
caractère nécessairement combat pas le
way paru quelques coups mais c'est une
partie à l automne pour l'instant on ait
eu que deux coups
ça promet de rezek notons par contre il
ya une belle égalité autant une heure
une heure partout pile poil pour les
deux joueurs un rythme de sénateurs
quand maman ils ont déjà dépensé à 40
minutes pour l'heure leurs neuf premiers
coups c'est beaucoup à ce niveau ou
est ici donc il ya eu il ya pas eu
cahier des 5 il n'y a pas eu fouet celle
qui était donc le goût de libye ne soit
pas le veltins nous aller dit fou des
six voici par un richard rapport
fera pas c'est pas le continent le plus
évident non plus puisque c
est là qu est ce que ça ok pourquoi pas
dams est un
coquin scène tels qu'ils élucident
récupération pions mais niet d5 est
parti on va essayer de défendre et
j'imagine que bp 3 qui était mal si
maintenant vous sur le clouage a été
loué
aux projections intéressante
est ce qu'on arrive à garder le pion
avec les noirs d'une façon ou d'une
autre déjà parce qu'à val ait à
synchroniser
en fait c'était son succès trombe et
trois autres cavaliers à sac et ben il y
avait deux dernières saisons
et du coup km à 5 500 m2 vis-à-vis de la
dalle et
ces deux visages mais
[Musique]
c'est leur attaque et pions
et si on bouge
à l'effet tequila beaucoup bras sakho c
est fou qui va peut-être rien pu face à
jake pas lui mais c'est vrai que c'est
encore mieux on peut manger à 7 et
ensuite atterrir peut-être ces cinq pour
empêcher le rock et les quatre roues est
très faible
donc attention ça va être une idée
claire bon cette thématique à cavalier
seul dans cette ouverture
dans ses positions
je sais pas si ces rapports a essayé de
s'accrocher au pion à la fois si ceux ci
mais ça m'a l'air bizarre mais
bon
draka idée simplement je
consommais bricolage
[Musique]
simple
car on nous demande si à 4 terrain
coulées de béton
certainement c'est dans le même ordre
d'idée
précise
les deux ruptures thématiques et oui à
6,1 stouff maintenir le statu quo au
moins
ce que peut-être plaint du coût attend
sur un 4 e du coriace en permettant
que tu veux fourche et t2 j'imagine où
vous allez à 100 cavaliers des deux
genoux et manger
normalement beaucoup de sémalens 21,6
pour d'étranges dessins qui madame n'est
pas grâce à un intéressant
mais bon c'est un parti fils hier c'est
un parti filmer un fait
ça peut tenir
ce que les blancs pour ici qu'ils
trouvent des mesures concrètes sinon
c'est pas si simple
ou oui position riche où beaucoup de
choses peuvent se passer ça peut tourner
dans des sens vraiment très différent je
pense
moi un 4/4 amendé dans l'esprit bale iii
qui a été préféré par quinzaine on va
voir comment réagira points s'il veut
s'accrocher l'assomption ou peut-être
justement finir son développement en
l'occurrence c'est aussi tout à fait
possible mais je pense qu'ils voulaient
pas ce comité soit quelque 3
m
et c'est qu'ils y avait un petit plus
blanche puisqu'il ya une meilleure
structure
si on rentre là dedans les deux
approches et quatre sociétés
plus pour reprendre et que le canadien
peut me ouais non mais et après j'ai
fait un combat que j'ai mené restructure
6 et 7 qui est qu'ils jouent les visas
les et après peut-être un jour ce cap et
prendre un bain de sang
ok c'est intéressant mais est-ce qu'un
important secteur at elle vraiment
besoin
[Musique]
nouveau de 1,8 dans les milieux deux en
fait téhéran d'avoir des solutions qui
sont jouables à plein de possibilités et
[Musique]
ouais mais attention un rapport qui en
forme d'un tournoi qui inspirait aussi
en milieu de jeu doukha
donc certainement un beau combat qui
risque de se décanter dans les minutes à
venir puisque la la comme on disait
relais te voir à beaucoup beaucoup de
temps cette ouverture à
moins d'une heure à la pendule après
seulement huit courts pour les noirs
donc
on verra cette catalane qui pose
question avec ce
froid donc tout à un coût est rare et
qui fait que tout de suite les joueurs
sont déjà même car c'est en fait c'est
lui qui a introduit trois mais
finalement deux ans plus tard il ya déjà
réfléchi quart d'heure donc
non parce que fout des six est aussi
rapide que c'était pas un coût principal
est de tout de suite ressortir à
quinssaines de sa part peut-être
ou peut-être que c'est une des raisons
je suis vert il est élu
c'est ça une partie d'échec c'est pas
les secondes entre le second dans ses
ordinateurs de l'un et de l'autre on
voit pas une partie moderne
regardez si duda il n'a pas pris encore
le cavalier
ouais où va-t-on
on va peut-être je tenais je tu vas
double puisqu'il y avait une suite fort
c'est que t'es pas inintéressant de voir
s'ils ont choisi de rentrer dans la
finale ou pas
carmona je vois la partie ferwana
plus je valu les inscrits de début de
partie
n'a pas de
il répète vraiment le plan 2 et nakamura
c'est vraiment nakamura guy en chef
avant d'acquérir
du coup comme ça ce sera plus clair pour
tout le monde maintenant le bon ton
style le tourteau stylo le tonton
d'acier
au monde et à bailly la voix exactement
nous était là et regardez justement
cette variante force ans je disais
pourquoi pourquoi pas m6 et m6 a été
levée par la cie penco
donc avec le christ et 6 pour pas perdre
de matériel mais à cheval intéressant et
c'est un coup il n'a pas voulu rentrer
dans la finale on vous a montré la
finale deux tours relance juste très
vite
mais nous semblait quand même assez
proche de l'égalité mais avec des très
petites des petits problèmes c'est ce
qui l'a jugé
et
ça donne à 8
alors parlons bien de voir qu'un scène
là tu peux être arrivé à l'instant mais
une seconde trop tard on y retournera
un petit peu plus tard on en est encore
en début de partie
dabo huit dames f3 d'oncologie
qu'hercule saddam kate et atterrit qui
est là où
assez un intéressant et ambitieux f5 qui
prend le contrôle de casey est ce que
d'après toi il veut envoyer aussi à
quatre derrière
alors non pas de le cam un cookie qui
marche au comité les noirs parce que le
plateau 5 qui est aimable et jouer avec
4 aussi ça pourrait être possible mais
ça nous beaucoup de cases noter que
je suis pas surpris
est ce que tu vas jouer ou cinq plutôt
de cire et que ça va le prendre puis la
tabbee sens puisqu'il ya quand même des
magazines et 5 et à gaza en juin 20 mois
peut-être plus cavalier fiscale et les
dessins sur quatre
[Musique]
mais doit
alors pourtant il a joué cinq agents de
voirie b4
dubois que tu essaies de lycéens blanc
héros
et super coup à jouer eux cinq ici donc
un coup comme on disait
à très responsable vienne 13 degrés
c'est pas du tout un choix notre de
sympa il veut prendre les choses en main
attention à pas comme sucrés trop de
faiblesses
des petites tactiques aussi parce qu'il
ya des diagonales
[Musique]
et
visuellement moi je sais pas tout de
suite quand je vois ça je n'étais pas un
truc là
ce que tu vois quelque chose tout
ou même dans la couleur d'un ou en os et
ios 5
le kama dépendra cavaliers femme
canadienne
prend 1,5
et
s'alarme auch pour les drar d'un point
de vue positionnelle a priori n'y a pas
de lapidation tahiti guy latour va
certainement hymne anciens
ou sans levée de visas j las pioncer cet
arn albion fc en carrière à cette
diagonale blanche laquée faible
même si c'est un peu faible et mal et
qu'il arrive on des 5
j'aime pas du tout les noirs ici
même
sans
cesse des arriérés de plomber 4 5 qui a
l'air moche on n'a plus eu plan à
l'appel lunaire avec la structure à six
et cinq sets en fait que le plan à 6 et
7 ans tout son arriéré mettre un pluriel
c'est quoi ces infos questionne qu elle
subit ouverte comme ici un
groupe armé n'a pas vraiment faible pour
l'instant mais c'est un confessionnal
souligne ouverte et qui a un arrière par
rapport à ces prédictions
adjacentes de jugement équitable
indépendant
bon y'a plus d'autres pions qui peuvent
le défendre je suis un certain temps qui
est indéfendable par un autre au plan
qui en arrière et du coup
pour s'arrêter je recommence
à faire déjouer ouais ok
michel a eu peur j'ai pas à quoi
construire dit moi j'aime bien les
blancs ici honnêtement alors c'est pas
bien ce n'est pas perdu pour les noirs
imbert ya quand même des faiblesses des
faits mais cette dame blanche allait
très bien placer dans cette diagonale au
ventre quand tu vois les pièces tu vois
que j'ai quand même chez les blancs
toutes les pièces sont en place et les
tours le cavalier la dame la structure
qui est en ma faveur et chez les noirs
va injecter 5 qui avançait ce qui
vous va tuer la technique du roi noir
final les tours qui sont pas encore
développés d'un peu mal placé
[Musique]
comment une position difficile pas
responsables il a joué directement ses
six donc essayé 6e il a envie de
empêcher la vallée des saints ouais
c'est sur un ca fait son principal un
mets le pied maintenant on va être parti
en b3 sur lui
pour viser ses 15 passes qui avait tombé
3 et ben je bloquerai vraiment les 2,15
à 5 et pas de faiblesse
mais mais trouver un chemin jusqu'au 8
mois c'est pas y arriver un aller sur la
case juste à côté de soi c'est plus
difficile pour un cheval donc
j'allais voir comme un certain nombre de
choses
mais je pense pas qu'il ait vraiment le
temps de faire cette manoeuvre il y
avait il à aucune autre case
ces trois pièces sont parfaitement placé
donc en fait j'aurais à me dire qu'elle
est bien steph le goût qui fait plus
sens ici dont
on n'a pas envie de toucher à ça c'est
trop bien placé il ya que lui qui peut
améliorer
après ce qu'il aura le temps de deux
terminé sa manoeuvre ça je sais pas ce
que peut-être qu'avec les danses et de
réagir
j'ai trouvé cette défense champions
aussi
j'avais dit dès 2 du coup est ce que j
arrive
peut-être à 5
ok ben hatira moon où les noirs peuvent
se retrouver bien celle ci à
6 arrive à avancer ses pions jusqu'en c4
rebondissent y mettre de la pression sur
1,2 mais normalement les blancs debré
pour empêcher ça
dans quatre
cas précis pour du baume au coeur
donc avoir position intéressante en tout
cas
avec l'arménie création pour un
pour l'aîné du joueur russe
de 3 n'en reviennent pas trop
la calle 2/3 du coup c'est pour un péché
f4 que tu veux faire je ne sais pas si
c'est pas un hymne à 0 80 g
en fait on est content déjà nous
maintenant je professe blanche on sait
aussi des couleurs avec du personnel
qualifié quatre probablement un très bon
coup et après la classe de 80 cavaliers
beaucoup de choses
c'est pas une bêta c'est donc trois
adversaires exactement 3 en plus tu te
fais bien volontiers blanche parce que
le jour où la même partie la toile micro
casque de cheveux blancs
suis pas fan depuis plus de trois ans
fait ça parce qu'il nous dit mais là je
pense que fx tempête c'est annecy gênant
en pièces pions ici si on veut juger
quatre
n'ont pas trop de problèmes sur 10 h-12
h point
d'impact ça peut paraître bizarre où
l'on emprunte par jacques attaque et
blanc passeront peut dire dangereux
comme le royal
vous permet bien quelle pièce noire
devant - quel point l'étape
on voit pas trop
froid apprendre à mener le cavalier en
d2 4 warren cavaliers de cavale et b3
voici le plan 6,31
je pense pas que vraiment vraiment une
faiblesse de quatre pense que justement
comptable devrait car ça ça protège leur
blanc seing ça donne trop de cases et
aussi oui le foot classement vraiment
hésité
j'aime pas trop
ouais moi voir ce que fait du buzz ci
joue d'amour et de caraïbes air ou pas
ses manières thème le coup le plus
logique ici
sur quel échec et bateau alors champions
ils ont toujours pas fait nul ou un
revenu
ils sont répétées mais un poil
évidemment 3 une fois damas avec dams
est quoi dame b 6
ok mais c'est marrant ces chants que
l'ordre et qui prend son temps les cinq
ils répètent un tempo il sait qu'il n'a
pas le choix où il a du mal à se
résoudre à annuler beaucoup on y
reviendra puisqu'il ya rien qu'à changer
ce qu'est ce qu'on peut aller voir
stouff ya dix mois à touts les voir et
ron entretuer work and
we dont je vais même plus loin il
ya pas eu beaucoup d'évolutions dans le
club si bon petit peu si comme
il ya eu pour ça le coup c'est le couple
et le tableau dakar alors dablement il
ya eu donc on a été là j'y venais de
jouer à cat
bonds fc8 paramo a dit qu'il veut jouer
en laissant sa tour invite à l'aide
d'armes avec les noirs mais ce n'est pas
une surprise vous pouvez toujours à sa
coupe tu me disais pour sécuriser
ces cinq
hockey
et donc que ce sera pareil on ne vous
l'avait annoncé que ça d'être
certainement le plan des blancs de
fermer le centre à prendre cette case
importante ce pion ça va être un vrai
levier peut-être une attaque soit pas si
on envoie jusqu'à plus tard
on va déploient les pièces vers le père
le roi noir
les limites
car elle y est fait
sa place est dans le canal est
généralement qu'il tenait hier soir
trois cars soit avec hk
l'avant pour g4
la dame est revenue je pense qu'on a
libéré une jambe et un souffle je pense
qu'il veut bessin généralement le latin
le
le plan des noirs et des jouets sur même
d'amande pendant que les banques
où je paie sa part il a joué qui sait
cette pour préparer un petit peu plus
j'ai l'impression et cavaliers en la vie
qui faisait pas grand chose et carmona
ici l'ajout et wash
wash chacun e mystérieux pour moi
première vue ou est ce qu'il va faire on
essayait
toujours de la chance
ce que vous avez des explications le
chat que quelqu'un fait tomber sur
l'idée pourquoi ce rouage
pour nous aider à revêtement j'ai du mal
à comprendre puisque oui comme juste
pour causer le pire mais ça paraît très
long dans les cavaliers qui bloque
le juge
pour gm pas intérêt
michel c'est sûr qu'il faut que tous à
la mode pour éviter les prépas mais du
coup c'est plus à la mode justement dans
les fonds marins des bleus a en partie
de rendre ça se joue un peu mais quand
même moins ce qu'on cherche davantage à
trouver quelque chose et surtout
qu'arras n'annonce pas trop trop son
genre
quand même très bien préparé il a
souvent débuté au contraire plein de
lignum fort sens où donc j'ai dit des
pardons
qu'est ce que tu proposes est au
chocolat
blanc qu'est-ce que ça change a mal à
voir
le jour pour la rupture avec leur 4 2 5
alors on a falck vainqueur 8 qui ne vous
dit peut-être pourra attendre de voir ce
que fait son adversaire à morges 3 le
pam ici c'est que
va dire il a un plan 25 cl il était en
situation était bloquée il savait pas du
tout quoi faire ça pourrait être un
ballon de faire un coup d'attentes pour
tourner le laisser un peu dans sa merde
on va dire sauf que la guerre il sait
qui veut prendre de l'espace il doit
attaquer l'homme dames qu'en fait c'est
juste un temps gratuit s'il n'y a pas
d'airé de trucs sur ce coup droit
mais il ya peu de chances que carla
drivée par une raison qui n'est pas vu
quelque chose juste il veut sans lever
2,7 des monnaies mais ça semble quand
même assez obscures
une idée serait pas d'essayer de
joaillerie 4g sont
g4 g5 torje un g4 g5 petit tour
du terrain sous couvert d'aidé parce que
généralement ce type de pollution en
réplication synchrone avec ash 95 et les
hanches et catalans on va sacrifier un
petit peu pas déjà réussi comment tu
verras tu prendrais où tu laisserais
prendre d'ailleurs au passage
avant de continuer ton plan
je pense que je prendrai pas si je
prends pas et les assedic l'allemand
gère donc tout bien géré les tc mange à
4 maj - 15 un trio rien
on va avancer mais aussi
j'ai j'aime de moins en moins
non mais j'essaie de voir vêtements
aussi en fourrage 3 et après j'ai cinq
passes qui aura toujours du mal à savoir
comment
va se découvrir ensemble dans les
prochains coups america laird a regardé
si vous voyez un peu à la caméra qui
fait sa bouche de sa boule de ces petits
clins
mais je comprends c'est un encouragement
seront achats en passant par exemple si
je fais pris ce prix là j'étais
ok je voulais jouer pour l'esprit du g5
toujours le a3 qui mange pas de pain 21
médias pour
[Musique]
manger
ah oui j'avais demandé ce qu'elle veut
l'idée de g4 et ça c'est pas forcément
oui lesquelles sont mal placés pour 100
m michel si tu touches un peu en retard
l'idée c'est pas forcément j'ai 4 ans
puis laissez pas d'enfant s'il veut
jouer à quatre mois
alors on va essayer donc on bouge le
cavalier met aux
enchères
en vrai rien je vous reprends pas trop
l'idée de de peyremale avec trois
chambres un smartphone c'est trop trop
dit pour nous la seconde de rachat
se cacher par où il veut le mettre si
vous jouez avec hatem c'est pareil tous
ces pièces il parvient à placer ce
cavalier juste pour rappel la frmsa rope
est
cavalli afin qu'ils valident le 3
elle est là la
logistique
avec rush 1 pourquoi pas voilà
ayew qui a terminé pour les genres
l'annuler si mal à le croire qu'ils font
des choix qu'ils remettent les pièces
larbitre si une boucle le plan froid
pour récupérer les faits et donc la
répétition et lieu bah écoute on a vu
hier on était plutôt bon je reviens de
nous jeter des fleurs saurait résister
c'est pas vrai on a bien prévu un petit
peu tout ce qui allait se passer
jusqu'au bout
belle réussite de près landes avec la
noire qui fait nul facilement grâce à
une bonne part au règlement pour
annuler sans jouer ça fait plaisir un
nul sans but avec le nord on suppose car
il avait dit dans ses fichiers sains
mais ça se trouve il était génial il a
trouvé la trouve en direct
il ya des chances
donc c'est notre premier résultat de la
journée et nul n'est dupe intéressante
du point
du coup on n'a qu'à d'avoir peut-être
car à qui john forrest
aller le jeune kevin karin von forest
donc on s'est arrêté à au fameux v8
parce qu'il y avait on fait quand on
allait faire
oui tu es l'homme s'est passé beaucoup
de choses donc c'est assez intéressant
donc ce fameux fou qui faisait une
partie de cache cache qui va
certainement se réactive un jour dans
cette diagonale
et karim kaddour h pendant que tu es le
coup qu'on avait prévu pour éviter ce
courage
pour huit parieurs et parlait juste
défendre l'option tranquillement
et aussi aux menaces prendre quatre
cavaliers quatre exactement
donc tu fous des 3 bat pour défendre
l'option
le bar caraquet on se remet aussi dans
une diagonale peut-être avec des idées
futur par rapport au rock noir
cavaliers sept cas l'air de sacrifier un
pur mais non parce qu'il ya une petite
tactique si on veut encaissé le pion
attention il ya ces six qui découvre le
faut et c'est la double attaque et noir
ont gagné une pièce
on n'a pas de solution pour sauver les
deux chevaux où est
donc le pion mais imprenable et
évidemment carrière qui n'est pas tombé
dans le panneau il a loué ses 4,6 il
veut prendre de l'espace
et la prise d'un problème aux piqûres
provoquent ce cavalier là il aura un
centre il sera bien
kg six opus transfert dont tu parlais
cavalli qui a atterri à l'endroit
et mine de rien si ça souvent par ici
peut y avoir pas mal de pièces activisme
qui vise le roi blanc avec les noirs où
vous n'êtes pas boxer ici c'est
évidemment c'est l'idée depuis le début
de libérer celui là et il sait 3 et du
coup juste pour le plaisir de nous
contrarier à jouer français
revient par là
alors ça fait sens parce que lecavalier
maintenant
de lui taper dessus vous
je veux juste échangé les foules de gaza
voire peut-être
retrouver la
d1 belge pas grand chose de
compliqué que je descendais way et
maintenant on vise la casse des f4
clairement
et intérieurs à ce sujet car éric yens 1
tout en m et d'avouer plein jeu
concentré beaucoup ici ont joué g3 fogel
tranquillement
sécurisant ce pion au bout et donc
empêcher les cavaliers de venir salt et
on attend
af447 est joué
la même c'est ce courage
3way moins froides en choeur
classique ç la déviation de charge est
trop
et
est du coup est ce assez pour dick parce
que des cinq a été joué
ça libère les deux fous et qu'est ce qui
se passait sur
brh crois
oui ok
exactement
[Musique]
et voilà que maintenant on se retrouve
en prison
donc ça ne marche pas et ce prise est
ici bonne foi ça choisi de fermer le
centre par ces cinq
dix et parti reste un charisme et il
s'écoute pierre il pourra toujours
échanger si besoin
est beau cavalier l' esprit qui sera
joli mais ça reste assez artificiel
hélas au caire
intéressante car et hakim des jeux à 4
ah non je suis bête noire de joie je me
suis trouvé ça sur 4
s'est vendu foirest qui joue un castres
lui même
ok alors qui veut pas autorisés à 4
doublant
ses calanques loi reprenant à deux fois
80 le pion pâte faible 1 sur le mental
fait mes classes b 5 qui attaque qui
avait bien repéré par les blancs il
faudra pas je vais seul tout seul avec
le noir si facilement
et bien non pas
pu venir là on sait comment avant leur
match de quoi
je suis pas trop fan de la position des
noirs pour être honnête avec toi j'aime
bien pas forcément une bonne nouvelle
pour à pour kevin voilà qui pourrait
être en difficulté
parce que la banque avait les noirs sont
un peu hors jeu qu'avait df4 ça va être
dur à faire et et puis à la laine dame
[Musique]
le pion à 4 il peut être faible c'est en
pays imaginé un coup comme rage 2 pour
jouer contre le cavaliere carrément
défendre les pièces sont en voilà
dommages et intérêts car pour les noirs
non je vois pas d'autres d'autres élèves
ouais mais oui ou alors sur f5 je pense
que je vois cavalli les deux se seraient
enfin par la case théâtre du bout de la
dame de fer cavaliers de et quand tu
joues avec 5 je mangerai l'autre un
camion la 4g à franges et de ces terres
assez de jeu vraiment urgent sur les
cases blanches c'est un peu ça dit mais
quand même cette partie c'est après
s'animer effectivement mais les blancs
tout cas il sera solide j'ai gagné le
préférence pour pour ici
car yakine moi je te rejoins souffre
effectivement mai
on n'a vu qu'une fois de plus la lutte
aura aidé comme assez inspiré il fait il
avait quatre parties décisives sur cinq
donc tout est possible tout peut arriver
ce qu'il faut dire
c'est clair
en ce temps on peut voir que très
rapidement après je pense qu'on ira voir
marc andrieu s'est tu veux juste pour
dire que double up il a joué il a joué
notre plan
global et b1 il a joué ici on était
discuté avec avec le chat ici cavaliers
bérété jouer donc on va essayer de
retrouver la casse ces 5 et 3 6 1 on
défend à l'horizontale l'occurrence et 6
et sur lequel j'ai déjà la réaction
attendue à 1,5 il faut trouver du
contre-jour peut pas se séparer et v3
et oui c'est ce pas vers la vie active
ou prix c'est normal puisque à trois il
ya eu prise en begag prise en bep cap et
aura quatre qui ont été intéressants
ici non mais je pense que moi j'aime
bien le coup et des points à 5 et l'a
essayé de faire pour ces deux pôles
daria pour défendre le pion à deux
actuellement et après à me gaver en b3
comme on avait planifié des biens est
resté sur ce plan c'est six auxquelles
ils vous grâce à des grâces attend que
ça faisait je peux aussi de doubler sur
le siècle le tour dames à vie pour
défendre
david huet et géométrie maintenant la
dame il y en a huit
partis donc bon il n'y a pas eu beaucoup
d'évolutions mais c'est justement pour
voir que de rester dans ce qu'on pensait
salut françois
son métier encore
peu commentée à l'investiture et à
touques m
là on va là on va le père adore françois
je crois si on parle anglais aussi
attends j'ai raté l'avion c'était quoi
sur
une tour à 3 pour soi basculer vers le
noir en betteraves on a fait le job air
derrière michel un autre perdu la
recette laquelle particules
mentionnait d'ailleurs
peut-être celle d'avant
brassard de jouer dans les crises
cardiaques in
c'était carrière avec le a4
avait
été intéressant à seyssuel tout de suite
sur ton seul de ses cinq bougies ton en
ce 5 et surtout points à 2 g dames des
cinq échecs d'acta tour à 2 et le 5
michel
et si leur voile à son tour ces deux ils
voulaient faire un an espère fêter ses 5
avoir trop pensé 5 et sur tourcoing deux
derniers cinq impacts à tora deux ans
plus tôt vous aux 5 et donc ya pas de m6
qui dépend tout
bon je sais pas mais
échec vous êtes sent pas très bon pour
le
battre on va juste manger ça
rentrait juste
en tout cas ça pulse et acrobatique a
déjà des pas perdus sur le champ et le
roi comme sans même pas forcément hyper
en sécurité
un peu trop risqué je pense la honte
du coup stouff on va aller voir marc
andré a peut-être y approfondit page de
pub exactement
réponse est ici
alors on était il avait joué dans ma 4e
budget m14 donc lui qui avait vite et on
se demandait un peu quel point il avait
trouvé mais pas beaucoup de réponses et
finalement il a opté pour qu'ait lieu
c'est intéressant
donc sur la prise
j'imagine que la crue de f4 et sa part
pense à la parole pour les blancs qui
hors du gatt et même jour être dangereux
donc
donc à roanne la mia et winslet appelés
à boire à tout prix
il a joué très vite essayé d'échanger
des dames et ingrédients il a plus ou
moins forcé
ou
presbytie
avec aussi les licences et en saas un
petit peu arriver ce que vous venez à
partir et si on échange déjà éruption
6,7 qui tourne c'est pas un coût
de 4
il a posté de manger le four c'est ce
qu'il a fait
ouais y attaquer à tour ans du coup ils
forcent se prend des 6 726
intéressés - du cavalier
est justement un tour s'impose des
problèmes mais ils sont la vente est
sanction que tu es faible dans la
colonne s'est s'est dit ok je double
édition moment je contrôle je contrôle
des casses finalement
est ce ici comme vous pouvez voir sont
pas des mauvais jours nous berçons pas
non plus l'action de l'année mais
des purs ne voulait plus dégueu que
d'autres on va dire ici sont dans une
catégorie
je vois aussi une utilité en tout cas
la cavale f3 est obligatoire pour
défendre les le flou
après on verra bien on a quand même du
mal avec les blindés ont attaqué ce pion
faible donc psg 5 ok menace g4 kaki des
villes cavalli pour manger le fou de
toi d'ailleurs pour dire le four alors
pourquoi ya pas dix fois en b 4 par
exemple avait peut-être eu à saint qui
juste si perrin en vérité n'a pas de
fonds pour acheter un
terrain les 17 et torah c'est un
tour assez vite qui est partie logique
et
bon va à priori s'il ya une position
normalement
on me dira de résultats
pas toujours gardé que les blancs ils
ramèneront des trois îles vice pression
échange les cavaliers avec cavaliers de
f3 et il ya quand même le pion des six
qui est un peu faible peut-être un jour
avec leurs amis leur en d3 jouer
cavalier de jouer f3c qui promeut tarf
où j'ai trois attaques un peu le pion
des six pouces et le 4
une position avec même une légère
il ya que les gars comme en a plus de
blancs voici sa mauvaise structure de
noir c'est plutôt une bonne chose parce
qu'il vient de perdre comme on l'a dit
beaucoup de parties d'avoir une position
d'avant où tu peux un peu respirer je
sais que tu crains pas grand chose si tu
fais ma de boulettes
pourra jouer lentement dans ce
fonctionnement presser un peu même un
une lui resta pas un mauvais résultat
erwan lalique acquis à 2622 donc mais
après on va essayer de te vois pas de
faire plus siècle et blanc
donc ok plutôt
une bonne nouvelle pour marc andré à
cette position
on verra comment comment ça évolue
stouff comme tu l'as dit on va faire
notre deuxième petite pause
et on va vous retrouver dans quelques
minutes donc pour la suite de ces partis
s a tout de suite
[Musique]
et
il
[Musique]
le
mais on est de retour ce tous y est sain
pour notre action je pense que vous
n'avez rien raté sarah passé de spécial
et on est revenu avec des bouddhas parce
qu'on a une position qui est un peu un
peu chaude on les avait laissés alors
que douteux s'apprêtait certainement à
manger en c5 ont récupéré les deux
pièces coûte la tour et c'est ce qui
s'est passé sans surprise par contre la
petite surprise parce qu'on n'avait pas
anticipé quand il y avait un échec
intermedia salut j'avoue qu'on n'a pas
du tout pour
la part pris tout de suite on sait 5 il
a commencé par david c'est peut-être
très bien parce que ce qu'on avait
regardé ensemble citer qu'eux ici avec
dark d'ascq
et donc ça explique c'était quand même
surprenant que ville et y rentre dedans
ça explique peut-être
d'être l'interface adam avidor voir ce
que ça change en sombrant f7
dépensé 5 maintenant d'un endroit où est
donc maintenant sur un fou comme d'armes
de 5 la nuance jean noir c'est que la
dame elle peut aller c'est jolie recette
géométrie de vidéos
alors je suis confiant quoi d'un coin à
l'autre de l'échiquier
et il posé de gros problèmes à ce roi
noir
fait beaucoup à tresser d'ingénieurs ce
qu'il
sait à quoi il a pensé le jour au zoo
et du coup il s'est passé quoi celui-ci
aurait ces dames des cats alors quelle
est la différence
ayew jouer à 5 sur damas chute
s'ils pensent qu'il veut jouer f5 j'ai
revu
mon défendre ici et sur dame pour
hachette
peut-être pour ça c'est peut-être ses
7es les projections
oui une tournure intéressante des
opérations mais on voit que j'ai dit il
n'a pas joué du coup
damages suite il s'est dit bah attention
sur un pion quand même hyper dangereux
je vais avancer
et damages suite d'un ça reste une idée
dans la position
où
on va tient tout moment mais mais en
proposant sion il ya quand même ce pion
passé et aussi les faiblesses sur les
plans achats de cette occasion indique
alain behr ici beaucoup faire attention
à ce propos
d'ailleurs pourquoi d'un problème de ne
serait pas bon et ce tout
particulièrement taillé à damas schmitt
et laure l'appui le défense
la bosnie n'a t-on à ce rythme on a plus
de défenses sur ses pions sur comme g5 à
l'esthétique les cités de 6 et 7 ans
derrière accès l'enfilade
thématiquement des finales 2% là où
transpose avec la même idée donc donc le
bref de il est imprenable et c'est
pourquoi des gens regardent eux
d'enchaîner les gousses pourquoi tour
6-7 a été joué et elle maintenant
et seulement maintenant visite à joris
d'armes damages facebook il a préféré le
faire
avec ses pièces ici plutôt que là
et du coup elle sent que parce qu'ils
sont si la partie est jouée à tembo voir
jean christophe
hockey intéressant
peut-être avoir des pépettes
derniers matches cinq victoires pour
avoir la cnsa
moi j'ai cinq
ans fait même ses finales là où tu peux
où je pourrais changer les dames en
plein week-end contraint de le protéger
comme compliquée
et s'il ne part pas ici
on va peut-être juste cool
ou peut-être atteint la même idée mais
cette tête
je sais pas qu'est-ce qu'ils paieront
l'art autour des trois ans peut-être
comme des six
mondial pour saluer le cloud tout
comme swiss team petter détroit je vais
être assez fâcheux le saura après
l'arbitré
effectivement
web michelle c'est réussi peut-être que
les noirs un petit plus
je sais pas si finalement
avoir intercalé ceux se ses 6
etait-ce bien ça pour visite après ça
reste complexe à la nuance entre est de
plutôt que dans ma chute tout de suite
mais
ce genre de position si
il ya pas mal de paix rhdp traîne aussi
un
[Musique]
leroy un peu faible
c'est à partir j'ai assumé il a mangé
achète la caméra s'allier visite à
montréal achète
donc on va voir si totalement schiste
auquel cas il y aura quatre points de
plus pour les noix donc clairement ici
si en revanche vous grincez duda
il va jouer pour essayer de forcer
peut-être un échec perpétuelle façon ou
d'une autre
et oui pour un pas mater
c'est un autre coup que la prise ici
je pense par inception c'est quand même
content de le manger
c'est quoi la suite après qu'on se
comporte en français si je me disais en
échec
ou avoir de 7 ha bon justin on peut pas
partir à ryad à me 8
wild fuite aurait pété
quaife 6 c'est débile ou encore moins 7
par être la seule charisme
et si super échec
à jim wright déjà complètes
de france donc
oui la variante plus égal mais ça ne
m'étonne pas
c'est quoi j'étais quoi
question qu'est ce qu'on fait après ont
combattu ne s'avère pas raison d'être
faut pas faire un chèque
est cher et on revient pour dresser ici
avec les plans n'a pas envie donc ce
comme important je pense que le montre
et je joue un coup pour illustrer n'a
pas envie de rentrer dans des variantes
où on échange les dames
parce que même si c'est un quatre contre
quatre
ça peut être très dangereux mais donc
voir son avance sur beaucoup plus avancé
donc
donc ici on va renverser de prendre avec
la tour plutôt
bon après la partie pourrait se terminer
comme ça
ok ben
justement
empêche de prendre avec la tour
et si on rentre dans cette finale on
vient dire peut-être allait-elle plus
dangereuse à voir et 6 3 7 5 en fait la
majorité qui allait monstre vite - oui
peut-être qu'on va voir ça d'un message
pour sa part fait mal un lycée on peut
pas se dépêtrer du courage du père a
porté un
[Musique]
voile un peu obligé de vendre
que sinon on va juste faire des
galipettes rapide
ok ok michel à
on a des choses d'hassaba nous regardons
et nous il nous fait mentir à duda
dit-on pioncer si je veux là je vais
aller faire une dame il a joué bekaert
ah oui il ya joué p4 dans son style en
attendent toujours pour l'agression
alors quoi la prise de risque
mais avec pasqua des coups sûrs en
danger c'est ici parce que maintenant
c'est pas la même
recette à l'encontre de ce fait ne pas
rentrer aux stands ce qui marche
vraiment
monter un champion il va à dame / plus
vite
donc
et donc on répète il cite le test
on a l'impression que les blues vont un
peu tourné trianguler avec l'art dame a
essayé de faire la paix rhdp est ce que
là maintenant il y
fait attention quand même pas attention
au moment où on part on n'a pas trop
fait gaffe à cette partie mais
mammadyarov et coin des lieux ont fait
match nul 1 à ok bon on va aller voir
tout de suite alors
voir tout de suite ce que le jour sur
mon corps dont ils ont quitté
l'échiquier déjà alors est ce qu un peu
décevant comme pour bâtir
je ne sentais pas aujourd'hui
mammadyarov où il ya eu lieu le berre
et il a choisi de mettre son fort g7 a
grandi lustres la tranchée la question
qu'on se pose en début de ce crime
s'impliquent mancelle la peuplant des
quatre vingts l'absence du pion aux
trois pour protéger
priori bien lui en a pris puisqu'il a dû
égaliser assez facilement
nul comme ça aussi vite
qu'ils attaquent une troisième fois le
pion d'un
g5 ces thématiques essai
en bleu le défenseur de casse des quatre
d'ailleurs de cap décidé par rapport à
sion aussi un sirop mention manger
bon à la fin il y aura des 80 on va
prendre des cartes ici
lé problème
donc il ya eu quoi il a pris avec le
cavalier d'amendé 4 et mamediarov il
approuve peser nul en échangeant les
dames aussi s'est dit que sa position
n'était pas ouvre son ouverture pas un
grand succès et vend des lieux ça priori
un très heureux de faire nul avec les
droits c'est pas un jour à 100 points de
plus que lui il va bientôt ma difficile
là il est en train de se remettre
d'aplomb après jour de repos avec ses
viennent de loin il a tu fais nul car tu
sais les mêmes erreurs d'affilée c'est
pas mal
on consulte pas sortir la tête de l'eau
s'écoule pour lui en tout cas
et oui après après on est quatre c1 il
tombé 80 heures
les
structures baignoire est quand même
assez mauvaise est pas belle
la paire de fou en fait on est très
actifs concrets pour les blancs ou
d'y couler si on veut enlever la
structure bien
quand on peut comprendre pourquoi on
annule ainsi les
entende un peu difficile mais d'un autre
côté il avait gagné position assez
prometteuse langue correctement un canon
il avait un peu de jeu mais c'est quand
même un bon résultat
c'est quand même un bon résultat ici à
faire nul donc ok statu quo pour
mamediarov en tête est ce que tu veux
qu'on aille voir carrick et ben ouais si
tu veux
changer les dames way solutions al
manara très très dur pour on est
vraiment en reste pour la voir
on était à a4 justement
à craquer je pense que voici je vois son
meilleur niveau dans ce genre de
position de manoeuvre très stratégique
il devrait être une supérieure je pense
à gondecourt est encore une si bonne foi
sortir de monter pour l'instant son
joueur l'impression il est plus basé sur
des idées sur d'explosivité du dynamisme
et peut-être encore un peu en deçà
positionne à la menthe ou cas là où il a
l'air de souffrir en cette partie la
great dane chase 5
messins qui a l'air très difficile un
positionnement on va bien on a une
police son style enfin on va dire
culturellement de hassen diane ou en
fait les blancs la cause des saints qui
ont défié faible et en fait j'ai
vraiment envie d'essayer de donner une
croix engagement en fait un plan qui
pourrait être pas mal quand des banques
on va essayer de voir c'est ce qu'on en
fait bon mais surtout championnat ce qui
s'est passé mark avait enlevé cinq mois
on a vu qu'ils avaient quatre donc ok
s'impose mais une importante encore des
blancs en ça va être un en données
nettes le roi en hd ou en g2 encore ce
qu'on veut le mettre l'idée vraiment
c'est de défendre le plan h3 pour
pouvoir après allait changer les
fauteurs blanche via 2 et g4 il a peut
être très fort parce qu'en fait vous
voir en échange deux occases moi le foot
à l'enjeu en fait on voit que le fou ces
villes c'est la seule pièce des noirs
qui leur offrent quelque chose notamment
être fou 17 aller manger le cavalier ça
comme ça on n'aime pas trop parce
qu'après on prend des cinq on aurait
rêvé les blancs kilomères s'acquittera
ans et qu'à
attaquer des 6 contre les bécistes sait
mais on voit aussi qu'une rupture des
blancs au point des noirs dont
pourraient dépendre d'éventuellement
faire f5 essayé d'ouvrir par là bas est
en fait du coup en mettant au fond en
jeu 4 eh ben on va soit échangé le foot
et blanche ce qui après deux paramètres
elle donnait pas de mettre un cavalier
par an sur trois et f5 très belles cases
en fait qu'on croit exploite avec les
blancs mais d'abord il faudra jamais
classement et si la mêlée est morte -
gkb
simplement je sache ranger 4 et puis
j'ai un gros globus magasin 5 une
colonne âge qui s'ouvre aussi pour le
blanc est un cavalier ou avenir en f1 3
f 5 et les cavaliers noirs qui seront
complètement dominé qui n'ont pas de
case d'envoi bien le crâne rouge et 3
les deux cavaliers peuvent pas du tout
venir sur casey's qu'aqmi h4 est en fait
on se demande vraiment
quoi faire tinga manière voilà les
cavalières et auront pas de gaz par an
créé des blocus sont dans la position et
j'ai l'impression que j'ai vraiment
l'impression que que
[Musique]
j'ai pas stratégiquement à la pression
j'ai gagné un gros avantage d'accord
avec toi mais le nature avec 2.4 qui
était joué même un ou une fois qu'on
aura changé deux manches tout roule 3 3
3 j'allais manger
le bekkat de
cartes jouées par caraquet c'est le
dernier coup la position au passage
merci merci à michel et salut salut
nathan des quatre lors des jo est donc
d'accord très concret
il perd pas de temps alors que c'est une
position comme tu leur expliques est
fermé on aurait le temps peut-être
demande est vrai que ça mais il veut
tout de suite profité sur davantage car
irakienne en tête devant la colonne a
juste pour illustrer en 44 des changes
alors j'imagine assez difficile surtout
il a pas de case en fait ça qui est
marrant et si on peut pas sortir pour à
cause du pion des 6 et donc d'un
problème dans la colonne ap on n'a pas
envie non plus d'abandonner le contrôle
avec les noirs
et on est déjà en fête avec un problème
concret ici non parce que même si que je
vous fous 17 km et condé 6 et vous
prendre à froid un bon de réduction mais
ce théâtre un pouvoir même ici le pion
des six il était très important par jour
de même pas
ah oui tiens je m'en fous mais hier je
pourrais même juste pour illustrer un
mangeas je crois justement je me
destine à 3,8 me faut d'abord un camp
fait à la fin les pions ventes ont bien
enregistré au tour à sept mètres un
cavalier en bessin que de nouveaux coups
sont des pions
ça va être compliqué parce qu'on a un
pion pas sa protégée centrale concerne
son doublé à l'aise ne fait rien du tout
donc forcément la différence entre les
deux et éloquence
beaucoup de problèmes commencent pour
vonn forest est ce qui fait qu sur b4
n'a pas encore pris en passant est plus
aussi de consolider sa structure par b6
et la thése idée justement d'aller
battre on a trois peuvent maintenant
aussi
arriver
ouais donc à les mettre au point mais je
pense que
je pense que pour l'instant
le l'urgence ce serait des robes à
l'échelle des échanges et les fous moi
j'aimerais si loin d'eux
j'aime beaucoup ce plan dont kung fu
ranger 4 qu'en fait on se rend compte qu
il n'entreprend rien ils peuvent jouer
moi si j'avais raison peut-être que
j'essaierai quand même je sais pas un
tueur s'est
donné la casse ces quatre japon qui est
encore chère que la case besogne puisque
la classique at lecavalier je parle de
verglacer grade si on arrive à les
changer ce fou contre ce cavalier
d'autres cavaliers du coup il va taper
et sur des six est sûre v6
après maintenant que maintenant qu'on en
parle
c'est avec le plan avec fo de fuji cap
va être difficile à réaliser à cause des
kamas des
basques avec sa soeur il n'a pas
d'avenir a pas revenir ici sans lui vaut
deux en fait je pensais me faire trop de
fautes directes parce que je fais
n'importe quoi mais les valeurs
canadiennes 6-4 j'aurais du mal avec à
1.248 de nathan jeu moyen parce que ba
hockey et bien sûr ce match assez
d'accord ouah et c'est très passif malmo
la tap une position que 20 des besoins
de défense est déconfite si son
adversaire le
pourquoi je pense qu'on va prendre un
une première victoire de karine entre
partis j'ai vraiment du mal à voir je
vois pas comment
[Musique]
puis je pense qu'elle est bien dans son
style là il va lever ses
dépendances et pas l'inversé
il a besoin d'avoir du jura il ya
peut-être trouvé une idée justement pour
tenter quitte à exploser en vol plus
vite momo à prendre sa chance plutôt que
de subir faire torturer pendant quatre
heures
ballaman et là je vois pas trop trop de
contrôles joue des tours de magie de la
perte de poids est pour vraiment
dynamique et dynamique et humanité
pardon je suis je pour choisir donc leur
est pas bloqué j'amène amin'ny j'ai pu
dit par le caravage pause 10-6
cette position actuellement
le côté
en plus c'est même pas oui non devant
l'espagnol et à combiner vachement
l'amicale
nom honni dynamisme donc encore plus
c'est même pas lancé le mouvement
normal à force de parler
on va voir comment il s'en sort des 500
à la caméra de la sonde langage corporel
la tal arabe la baie d'yves en hausse et
créative lâché
je pense ni
qu'est ce qu'on va retourner chez magnus
peut-être sentiment qu'on a pas vu le
champion du monde
contribue
grandes villes du monde entier s'est
aussi dit rien
on
va tous aller les voir personne il y a
eu la prison ces quelques mots n'avaient
10,1 avec avec dams et un dessin je
connais tu es là donc dame c1 et 25 b3
et là il a choisi de rendre le pion
rapport rejoint fou 17 ans d'aller
regarder ce qui se passe et si vous
voulez s'accrocha
possibilité mais c'était pas si loin que
ça
l'a rendu le pion carson a pris
directement il n'est pas allé chercher
avec le cavaliere
alors qu'amélie de b4 t on pas le temps
de roquet c'est intéressant quel est son
idée en voiture à trois il veut bien sûr
pour la classe des 5 alors qu'il faut à
6 kg s'éviter un j'imagine
km et bekaert est une fois six coups des
cinq donc probable un peu tout ça la 3d
je vais par quinzaine ok d'avoir si je
crois aussi sous des sacs poubelles des
cinq éléments ton idée la joie qu'il
était cinglant sur fois ci je pense que
juste bouger la dame ait gagné une pièce
je m'en rendre compte
par agacer si ce jugement sais pas je
n'ai pas le temps de manger devant la
peta
je souhaiterais faire une grosse gaffe
interventions dont une pièce les coins
tam n'a pas toujours très parce qu'on
croit que tout - ouais on est heureux
dans mon lacet le général ne faut pas
faire un coup à intervenir pour faire
corps intermédiaires c'est comme vous
pas faire échec pour faire échec il faut
qu'il y ait une utilité derrière qui
suivirent vous voyez donc le roi noir
est toujours en 8 vous avez par ok donc
nous amuser pas avoir trop de maliens
en tout cas voilà il faut avoir au moins
le niveau de stock pour se permettre de
doubler plus librement avec ce genre de
petites histoires qui se planquent
d'am-dam sécher
donc je l'avais dit en d5 avec son quart
à l'ats roger cinq fois qu'ils étaient
là la nouveauté en tout cas la petite
surprise de 15 ce n est donc pas très
bien passé si la couvrirons f6
l'attention que maintenant je me
d'actes mans à 7,20 thématique d'autres
qui étaient bel et bien si ces garde
temps sur la dame donc on va voir un sur
quatre kamel et b6 attaque adam et qui
ont attaqué deux fois aussi le 3e quart
temps
après on sait pas s'il peut on vraiment
en prison ferme alliée cissé est cloué
mai mais en tout cas on comprend que les
blancs dans leur camp pour jouer le 4
d'ailleurs il va finir à bord son
développement a donc validé deux magnus
est logique on pose la question faut
résoudre ce cercle rouge ali a pas trop
le choix il peut pas trop reculé il a
mangé il ya vallier prend
cette diagonale et qu'arsène à jouer
tours fc 1 ce qui est logique puisque
ici on son petit avantage dans la
position c'est qu'il ya ce procès c'est
l'option et d'enlever 6 et même les
noirs qui serait
peut-être pas forcément au mieux mais
ballmer au landeron ce que dans la paire
de faux même
d'avoir le flou
mais il ya aussi les
baignoires pardon ont le contrôle de la
case de 400
à noter parce que si l'on pouvait jouer
cac librement ils réclament un
engagement
moi j'ai un peu du mal à jeu 4 pour
l'instant peu de detroit alors se voir
de jolies ces deux joueurs
je sais pas si ça sera refaite on
indique qu'au 16e coup depuis le début
cette partie vous a dit que les devoirs
je me calme plutôt très lentement ils
ont maintenant en gros une demi heure
chacun donc pour jouer encore
qu'en 24 25 août c'est énorme
il pourrait y avoir un gros i'm not ce
profil
ça va dépendre de ces où la position
reste un peu tendus ou de simplification
qui feront que wasaï note dans une
position simplifier c'est trop facile à
gérer
et d'ailleurs on voit
en direct la vie dit qui y est l'uda qui
font nul donc sfr des peines il ya eu là
dommages chez toi tu es là ce qu'on
avait regardé ensemble
nous ont pas demandé si donc sur b4 il
ya eu d'alger 6.7
non ça c'est là que je mets à jour
pardon
j'ai un bac 2 je ne sais pas qu'est ce
que j'entendais dans le menu ça ne
s'actualise pas
à ça devrait être bon
avec
donc sur b4 à la machette l'échec rodez
est là damage fils qui revient et
oui cette idée a besoin qu'elle n'était
pas aussi forte que tout à leur banque
la rendrait pas bouger plus encore
c est aux répétitions comme ça
c'était propre attendait
aux siens on écoute un résultat bout
c'est une assez bonne opération pour les
deux joueurs mais des petits ponts sur
l'île à christophe un bon tournoi à
dubaï dangereux où il ya vu les droits
parce qu'il est toujours ici sont assez
contents bruins ont joué leur parti
jusqu'aux pour
rien à leur reprocher c'est une vraie
nul ici
une partie qui est assez intéressant
d'ailleurs l'une des faces assez
créative
donc j'ai fait trois nuls aujourd'hui ce
tour
et
49 secondes à la réponse on va aller
voir ça ensemble dans ce mystérieux
roitg j'ai passé n'a t-on encore dans le
chat pourrait peut-être nous apporter
ses lumières
c'est tout nous ont rejoint messi
était là et là car on a donc le juriste
ou froids ch
vous avez scotché
alors la toile seront à chanas temps est
ce que est ce que tu vois une
explication sauf à être opposé à l'idée
de jouer à battre g4 g5 mais s'est pas
révélée l'hyper convaincant
sachant que le plan d'eau assez de
d'envoyer
d'envoyer certainement allèles dame
la lumière sera porté par kasparov tu
devrais parti ne soit pas dans le chatt
karpov et si tu connais personnellement
et spa
michel ça nous fait que plaisir l'oira
d'avoir carpe avec nous
néanmoins il est plus présent au cap
d'agde en france où je veux être
sensible inauguré aussi de recevoir
visite
en tout cas star wars
toy là il ya eu des cinq donc laguérie
lui a fait ce qu'on attendait lui
et
il ya du coup j'ai validé quatre a été
jouée
par cars wanadoo
et rose avec le droit européen
[Musique]
il ya peut-être il ya peut-être touchés
sont droites il arrivé
non mais qui est des 4 à 10 ans en fait
oui ça allait bien en ce moment mais
c'est ça libère le point mais là on
avait dit pouvoir chance mais
pour joseph 4 way à dax où un instant on
et puis moi dans sept des lamés
et surtout après la prise de la bastille
entreprise aura quatre ils ont attaqué
la partie avec avel et b6
comment regarder les propositions de
chaque canadien sait des choses que tu
avais dit un peu me 7,7 secondes bon
alors on l'a où on l'a même dit g4 g5 ou
c'est cette fin mais c'est trop comité
pollan s'est pas les pieds trois tacles
et déjà
au québec - 4/6 brutale en ce sens il
veut pousser les pions mais c'est là un
peu lent aussi entre nous
donc on va voir caprice prises espacées
quoi et c'est sûr que c'est dans les
années il a vécu la déception donc dame
lui probablement
avec une
découverte son cavalier par la kabbale
et b kamel et b6 si je m'attaque hier la
loi
c'est ça ce cavalier est l'objet de
revenir d'où il vient en fait après tu
mangeras un cadre avec le fou et ça pose
problème
c'est pas la partie il n'y a pas mangé
intermédiaire du coup ces six caruana la
reprise directement
et jerry a jamais cavalier b6 keller
même logique hein
ça peut transposer tout un
même pas atteint franc succès en cette
ouverture pour pour les blancs
c'est plutôt eux qui ont maintenant des
problèmes à résoudre
c'est maintenant le cavalier la galerie
noir qui arrive à la rescousse et qui
met la pression
cavalli et b3 hockey
est ici là le fouet cette circulaire ce
qui pouvait pas
parce que les sacs il est bizarre pas
forcément envie de le manger
pourquoi trois sapins coup je ferai
axway pour essayer de gagner de temps
mais c'est contre un mois j'étais
correct est
fixé
à 6 ans vont sûrement être cathy va
partir et on aura
on aura donc là peut-être la
justification secours h à traiter
alors que cette pollution là je prendrai
quelques couleurs à une gloire
c'est intéressant justement je sentais
que ça allait pas bon pour les blancs
j'sais pas si geri est une barre précis
dans cette petite phase tactique la
voix la voix c'est de jouer 5
les pièces blanches bahamas en question
pas si bien passé qu'on va perdre du
temps moment le plan assez clair aller
doit renvoyer
le pion aux 7 le tèf
bas ici je suis commence à trouver les
blancs moi ok
même si on a perdu du temps dans le sens
où le plan me semblait évident après
un très bon dalle dame un petit peu
et la dre statique c'est sylvain explosé
salamanque l'air commence à s'y attaquer
en tout cas il manque des pièces
lecavalier partie en b3 avant cavani
vient à angers 4
moi je suis pas fan des blancs en fait
peut-être qu'en partie je prendrai les
blancs parce que ben
je préfère attaquer avec s4 eto'o tu
vois
donc je pense que le plan des blacks on
peut être plus facile à jouer avec f 4g
4 1 comme ça une tâche rendue possible
en partie mais je suis pas fan de la
position de moyens fait sur l'idée
regarde de manger les cavaliers c'est
que sur ce clavier tu as beaucoup de mal
au f5
avec oui voilà bien sûr ça que ça
pouvait être intéressant de manger
cavaliers ici clairement
c'est sûr d'apprendre à tapis de plomb
la pression mais par contre pour le
fouiller pas exceptionnel et les
biennois ils vont pouvoir continuer leur
un jeu
mais un jeu à l'aide à peut-être que
j'aurais mangé ce cavalier mois
après c'est très hypothétique tout ça
mais moi je pense qu'aucune chanson
les problèmes bursa j'aime trop la part
de fou pour
les cavaliers
alex karidis qu'un oncle lui lui qui
permet le plan blanc quoi sens cavaliers
moi m'ont foutu touche pas quoi
mais bon pourquoi 3 et programmes
ailleurs comment un maître
[Musique]
g passe compréhension qu'ont donnés
comme ça je
le remet en garde est ok mais en tout
cas intéressant moi j'aime bien les
noirs à ses besoins voilà une partie
tout peut se passer m impression chacun
de son côté
on devrait avoir un vrai combat dans les
prochains jours et puis elle tend bien
sûr qu'ils rentrent en ligne de compte
les deux marseillais sont passés sous
sous la demi heure ou presque donc ça va
ça va se décanter je pense dans le
multi prochain coin il y aura beaucoup
plus clair sur qui qui joue pour le gars
ici la jarre sont les deux joueurs
peuvent à la france kerry d'ailleurs à
jouer avant de changer d'âme 17 points
17 rebonds qui paraît logique qui
empêche f5 aussi parce que ça empêche 25
face à contrôler à 4,5 du risque de
refaire ça m'a peut être ça c'est notre
fait nous laisse encore même si tu
prends avec quoi
je me dis que je fuis tu vas pas d'être
fou
[Rires]
pas réponse à
tout et si je ramène tout à
fait à part ce geste pas très envie de
jouer si je vais récupérer donc si c'est
pour faire des six autant me donner le
foulard mais
moi je commence à dire non parce que je
voulais écrire un peu mou
il avait une belle position il est
chargé quatre ans
ok ok pas de même 17 sarah cook et leur
logique en tout cas sans la peau car le
chic mais
metaxa cette carte est plus là et merci
quoi il a davantage la halle d'ajouter
quoi un peu
ses sept c'est vraiment excitant phf 5
mai 6h 9h pas vraiment f5 n'était pas la
priorité en tête et du cou leurs
collègues je crois la bonne dame de 7,5
ces
cinq essais de faire ces quatre mais
c'est 95 des quatre mais ça va c'est
vrai la colonne c'est demain tour
parce que l'idée en fait c'est qu'une
fois que je fais c'est 4 éveille un truc
important c'est que je peux aussi à un
jour attaqué avec cavale et bekaert
cabale et c5 les pions ces deux des
trois ans wasquehal flash 7,1 camara
rôle défensif est aussi très clairement
non c'est intéressant jeu ça me semble
beaucoup plus dans l'esprit on de jouer
c'est son
chéri ça reste un joueur conservateur
donc
dit que j'ai raison su régler ça me fait
plaisir
c'est plus facile quand on n'est pas
contre des chez soi tranquillement les
bras croisés face à sa partie est une
histoire de style aussi
chez pas ici on a l'impression d'en
venir aux coups
de pied
après comme 17 l'idée de ces sacs aussi
elle a du sens avec un valet prince
oui oui bien sûr c'est bien
mais c'est juste un peu plus mon coin
et d'ailleurs avec cinq parties fabien
je vais remettre le récit là leur caméra
parce que là on est sûr été chiche
évident
baby fatigué rires et de joie qui sont à
table via les dents ça dans sa pause
habituelle à tête entre les mains sa
course entre elles
et f5 il a pris 1 il a pris avec l'optio
aussi ok il c'est la partie avec 5
prises à un peu ce qui s'est passé on va
aussi rapidement là pour moi je suis là
je suis surtout un temps on voit carré
coup qui a mis le plus qui a mis la tour
on aura droit à
du beau être commis à 3 ans et 5
donc je serai là franchement on est là
on a été bons partout j'avoue darcos
par contre 4,5 évidemment à 7 alors ça
par contre je vais pas parler il s'est
passé plein de choses chères youtube aux
seychelles est monsieur grand palais des
congrès à moscou avaient chacun s'est
passé religieuse
et puis les deux joueurs qui étaient mal
au tendon qui lui surtout obligé
d'enchaîner les coups plus vite
sur un cheese civils et changent
et pour s'arrêter là
cavalier revenus se replacer au 17
être pour rien peut boucher les trous à
l'album
michel supporters peut-être de
2 km
barakat une petite faiblesse sur l'a7 il
la fixe il a tellement gestion du
coustou vent
ouais c'est simplement une réaction
énergique et 15,7 cas pas peur tu
apprends à cette
voiture ils le mangent
hockey dont s'il n'y a pas de
contre-indication
la raison sont tus roi pourrait apporter
la victoire plus tard
et on prend 1,3 étaient joués
7 comprend à l'idée de rap war
base sur deux
il va jouer tours à huit est récupérée
à 3 sur quels alliés plan il veut jouer
truc comme ça je pense
récupérer le bateau je sais pas si on
prend la récupérer à 3 alors de foudre
ayant fait ce qu'il veut jouer saint
gall qui voir ce n'est pas dû qu'à des
lycées 6 des high point il ya tour
emprise de la part d un câble et c5 a
priori ce point il veut sur bon tenir un
truc complètement égal et leur poser sa
patte au
salut pas tous les anniversaires encore
lui à toi ça les dicos aussi
supporters de babette dubois fois les
joueurs les joueurs concernant six fois
donc ça c'est le rapport si tu dois
garder le rapport d'une commission
puisque rapport il envoie d'ailleurs
cette position
nous dément pas puisque il a été
sacrifié quand même le petit prince est
pour essayer de s'activer donc d'un
point à 7 points f3 et on vient de voir
que sûr qu'avec trois stouff son idée ce
serait ça espérer
car pardon d'abord pour invite celui
d'allié saint père et une simplification
massimo
soit mieux car ce n est certainement pas
forcés de rentrer là dedans
et
réfléchit à ya réfléchi ici peut-être
réfléchir à manger du fou
d'ailleurs c'est une option peut-être de
manger du fou
contrôler la casa vite
après 4 il va falloir que je règle que
je réussisse à récupérer donc d'un point
dé 4 au babc le mans
et ira n'entend rien fait au sans faute
5 qui va nous clouer la dame pas nous
qui nous en fils on peut le dire c'est
officiel enfilade innovant fils qu'on va
éviter des mésaventures fâcheusement
qu'il est non c'est pas le jour
c'est le plaisir ça nous regarde pas et
je vous en remercie
et des échos
c'est une idée pas si reprendre nous
faut un très beau il n'y a pas de
fondement et à manger à 7 ans réduit
avec le pur pas s'éloigner à contre les
pions centraux c'est peut-être pas le
meilleur et donc et on l'a vu la cave
si c'est ce qu'il a choisi et au fond de
jeu
il a mangé du flou c'est nous qui il
veut éviter les v8 et les les
simplifications harcèlement on voit
comment qui joue le gars c'est cool
c'est beau ouais et
et rapport qui a pris à tempo ont des 4
donc ok c'est un pseudo de sacrifices
d'options et la récupérer moment la
position ces déséquilibres est
maintenant dans le sortie plutôt contrat
peut pas s'éloigner des fous de couleurs
opposées
mais sur intéressante
cavaliers je pense qu'il va et qui va
s'activer
je commence à johnny peut aller très
vite
quand vous avez un pion comme ça passait
sur la colonne à vaches ouais et vous
avez le fou c'est plus souvent
d'ailleurs le cas sur la colonne
accident du petit côté et du coup la
dame a plus souvent tendance à
disparaître donc quand vous avez le fou
dans la grande diagonale et en plus une
tour et arrière le pion aux supports
c'est une vraie fusée espions fait
pour trois plaintes ont alors essayé à
partir alors que les pions centre des
noirs ne peuvent pas trop avancé pour
l'instant est en fait les noirs il leur
manque clairement le
hilarant clairement le foot cases
blanches en fait qui permettrait de
lutter contre le pou r 3 contre lui la
casa 8 donc dans une bonne position pour
moi c'est un pour les blancs j'ai
l'impression ses pions à qui peut être
très très dangereux pour l'instant on
dirait pas comme ça mais il faut que tu
en seras avancer un peu à 4 à 5 à 6 ça
pourra des gros dégâts la torah de
prophylaxie qui doit empêcher
tombé 2 est aussi menace d'un prend des
quatre parce que maintenant il ya plus
fous et 5 avec enfilade sur la tour 1
exact simplement nous de manger le plus
long que l'on va voir comment il va
réagir à ce qui va je eu 5 pour défendre
le pion de 5,5 moche ses impressions
c'est trop les cases blanches
c'est bien sûr case âge ouais et en plus
tu te tue un peu le foot 15 mois
mais comment défendre bas même si c'est
peut-être la cavalcade
a tiré en l'air en plus axée sur les
petits cônes à
14h 16h15 nesc donc prophylaxie comme tu
me disais pour la seconde rangée on
s'enlève des visages y est on prépare
doublage
j'aime beaucoup ce que tu auras de vous
garder deux options pour notre eau notre
cheval et à
et on va commencer à envoyer le pire
aura donc moi je verrais bien une
pression comme d'hab long ici il va
devoir être précis normes et les
prochains coups elle reste centré par et
cavaliers 5 en disant que sur demande et
4g peut-être des thèmes tactique
complexe pas si sa marque en plus mon
idole
je voulais essayer de faire marcher
trois points
par rapport aux cavaliers des deux mers
suis fou prend la 3 j'attaque la dame et
la tour a priori schwarz le change des
dames si la dame rouge le cadre
est donc l'idée c'est qu'après cette
tour elle ne peut pas avoir la double
casquette de défenseuse
défenseuse mais ce patch samba du
cavalier
sexe féminin j'essaie de donner le comme
tu dis professeur c'est une professeur
pas une pro b se ré mais voici que je
n'aurais pas avec toi
lâche un mec dans le chat le soutien
d'anna
sous
3 2 et ça évidemment les amis ça amènera
une mieux en vous pouvez voir
scientifique à sion massive
heureux merci de chamakh un
magnifique elle est là
ou
est ce que tu dirais une dépense de ou
une défenseure e
ouest au filet binaire
bref c'est une mode jeune défenseur
serbe ont gardé chez pas que ça ne
marche c'est la règle de manière à
supprimer le message
tu as fait ça oui c'est moi qui s'est
passé pour toi c'est quoi sa sensuelle à
jouer avec ta vie mon chien stopha
donc
voilà
il peut rien m'arriver de plus
l'argentine
un pro du dictionnaire qui nous
proposent les dépôts d'être brutal
nous proposer de se faire une raison ça
va moi je partage
mes mais villa lobos tout fait pendant
ces débats sur la longue durée de cinq
ans
si je prend 1,3 marche ça peut bien
liquider mais il y avait sept ans nous a
pas écoutés apporte la jouer le plus
d'amis set qui allait assez moulant
prête-noms pour ajoie 4
il veut mettre une pression sur ce bio
est recréé un échaudé d'avril astou fait
sa semaine de rêve qu'on fait c'est
mignon c'est pour cela je trouve en fait
ouais sauf que sont plus classe
d'âge sais pas ce que laissent tout fait
et bleu aussi d'ailleurs
ce que des bleus elle peut être bleu des
fois
et djiboua cap peut-être tiré géré par
quinzaine
mam indien il va mettre la marche en
direction de shaw et qu'est ce qui se
passe juste à ce qu'ils mangent le pion
des cas tuera faut prendre froid
évidemment je pense qu'ils s'en foutent
ce furent des quatre pour l'instant il
veut juste well mais les voir ils
veulent échanger les pions en fait donc
on a de quoi ce serait vraiment le coup
pour la wii la pollution les toros et
l'assainissement symétrique et plus qu'à
placer des pièces ça va non à quatre
c'est en fait le pion à il a bien plus
de valeur que le clan des parce que le
pont d'yves annuler par débloquer kraft
place blanche le foot pour la casa us
elle passe de promotion et ben les noirs
ont beaucoup beaucoup de mal à à venir
empêcher ça et à se défendre et grâce à
tout ça vraiment je pense que je pense
que les blancs
c'est le pion aux lampions usain bolt
c'est à base de rapports je commence à
me faire du soucis à leur tête il va
essayer de trouver d'autres jeux au
centre excel à sa majorité mais ça me
semble plus évident
on va perdre ce talk show dans ça va
ok position prometteuse pour le champion
du monde ici qui met la pression sur
rapport les deux joueurs moins de vingt
minutes
il reste pas un coup par coup pour 20
minutes donc autant dire qu'il va pas
falloir
alors trouvé quatre boîtes pas
maintenant mais à 4 ou b 4 à 5 à 4 b4 ok
je suis parent je te dis je ok je pousse
mon cavalier défendue par le tour et
binger fer à simandou
madame et je vais faire à 7 ce fou est
vraiment surpuissant contrôler la casa
vite tels moyens tant ici ouais c'est
clair
c'est sûr pour les doigts ce que peut
être que justement ça qui est ça que
j'aimerais bien il ya peut-être santé
sachant s'ils
rapportent de créer des menaces sur ce
faux alors qu'un celle d'un garçon il a
joué à cache
savons pas du digeon logique ils nous
écoutent et l'invention petits plots 24
cases de la dame tout va bien
ouais non je pense que garçonne excédé
belle option pour convertir le point
la pression est de plus en plus
prometteuses ce que la clope au genou
nul au nul c'est une partie nulle ça
toucherait
2 et le c2 elle c'est là nul oui c'est
pas toi qui es nul le sait j'adore
raconter ce fut un match nul mais oui
pendant deal en fait on sous-entend une
partie nulle mais ça
ce sera 2 l otan on peut dire un nul
mais c'est cette puce en foot
c'est pourquoi tu parles super de
résultats de matches française car c'est
ça c'est assez logique juste dans le
sport bah foot hand etc on parle du
match aux échecs on parle d'un parti
12h11 d'orthographe
ça mais je crois que celle là on va
devoir vous laissez faire une pause à
paris c'est à chacun chaque heure à
chaque l'art verrier heureusement en à
l'heure on a le contrat avec chose comme
et twitch on obligé de vous faire une
page de pub mairie dans le triste de
ward vous en voyez là du club on revient
dans quelques minutes pour le dénouement
de la tête de cette partie qui alors
quand même très intéressante a tout de
suite à un peu de sucre
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je suis de retour
tout pour l'instant n'est pas là mais je
pense ne devrait pas trop tarder elle je
ne sais pas trop ce qu'ils fabriquent
mais vous inquiétez pas il va revenir
parmi nous
récupérons
monde est revenu avec la partie car en
algérie on reviendra pas le voilà se
trouve au fond d'un dialogue secret bien
avant que tu te dis une bêtise je te
connais le tueur venu tu ne m'as pas
averti bah si mais je ne répondais pas
depuis plusieurs minutes je suis
inquiète et pour ta santé
le message beaucoup à mes amis ça
du coup des revenus
n'a donné qu'un one algérie puisque
c'était quand même deux parties très
chaude en plus c'est un choc contre la
tête de série numéro 2 et 3 du tournoi
karmann hakim était peut-être la
pression sur le roi de guerriers avec
les blancs et lyrique c'est de réagir
avec la dame même s'ils s'étaient
montrés un petit peu mou dans ses
dernières décisions alors elle s'en
venait d'être joué les trisomiques cinq
mois était là stouff
vous êtes tour est pas moins évident
mais croit dans le dans le même esprit
pour les récupère espion et ouais
dirai jamais caressé 5
alors on voit qu'ils apportent des
cartons finalement il veut échanger
ses cavaliers
fait m'occuper ont des idées si jamais
les blancs
ne mange pas en b3 le mans je pensais 5
avec l'idée de faire cavaler prend b3
pour les bleus pour les noirs
et ensuite se faire f 4 pour aller
manger le pion détroit avec le fou tu
vécu permettrait après d'installer un
fou en quatre parts assez loin ok je
pense que c'est une [ __ ] à l'inter aux
menaces de manger un car de fait si
les blancs ne mange pas et c'est
certainement parce que sinon les lois il
aimerait bien ramener un cavalier
mais le problème c'est la prise du
bureau à quatre trios rires
je pense que c'est pour ça que quinze
mois dans la grange à cinq voix près
sous prend hélas jouer des quatre
missiles des cas donc il en quarts sont
fous mais il consolide son simple au
centre par cette décision importante
long
way
joue des quatre hockey puisqu'il donne
aussi la casse et quatre pour le cab
allée b 6 ouais si
convaincu comme ça intuitivement bien
sûr de ceux des casses
ouais mais bon
il veut
donc avec fois je crois peut-être des
quatre fois je crois mais sur g6 psg 4e
cadet il tout en faisant parler un camp
tu as voulu faire g600 organise qu'on
avait auparavant
il ya toujours le coup g4 qui peut à qui
peut arriver à très fort en feutre
pour pour les blancs et en fait du coup
ici on voit bien si jamais les blancs de
la fois je crois directement il doit y
avoir des trous prend 2,3 pour essayer
le
défendre le pur f5 tranquillement mais
pour la paire de fou j'aime bien les blu
ray si
tu regardes ça capable de récupérer je
pense un jour ou l'autre parce que je
joue j'essaie mais là ça revient à
envoyer directement four en prison
qu'il faut qu'ils aient déjà pas très
joli
j'aimais bien
ouverte aux cadets carte ça fait bien
sûr sens ouais et maintenant après fou
hausse est fou et chute au squad m
et ben est bon pour avoir fois je crois
sans se préoccuper du fou prend un point
tout à l'heure mais j'ai au gagnant ça
qu'il ya donc cette case c4 maintenant
qui a
donc à voir ainsi si vraiment on peut on
peut se permettre de jeu camel et c4
parce que c'est quand même aussi dingue
pardon
caisse et 4 ce que je peux manger la
fnac de suite non je pense pas ça
m'embête je suis pas sûr qu'on va garder
et elle prend un crack maintenant en
fait tu peux pas manger en b2 parce que
j'ai cavale et prend hc se gardait bien
et un vis-à-vis entre le fou l'adamant
ça c'est déjà comme un fou importante à
voir et est sûr qu'avec l'épreuve 5
surtout première 5.9 ça que j'ai même
temps sur la dame où l'on pourra
repartir en cfa j'ai aussi la tour c est
un honneur surtout
donc car elle prince un canard au final
jouable en au début je n'ai pas vu la
verte avec le tram
séparables donc à ces gars t'as pas
l'air terrible c'est pour les droits non
mais du coup si jamais un noir ou g6
c'est là que je pensais adjugé 4 ça fait
sens un fou c'est ça et maintenant aussi
que le pion est arrivé en g6 et bien le
plus rage 6 lui ai donné pas défendu et
après être franc j'ai quatre j'aurais
cavaler projet 4 avec un tempo sur le
gave sur le plan hts le footballeur en
c1 et a aussi la découverte du fou h3
sur la dame s'est vite ça va très mal
tout ça beaucoup de problèmes louis ses
flèches mais la diagonale blanche à ses
meurtriers c'est la diagonale
h3c vite
puisque les thèmes sur le roi donc voilà
ça ça va pas les du dow jones va pas
rentrer là dedans
sur ces quatre peut-être ces deux jeunes
hommes f4 ça devient assez acrobatique
avec l'idée je pense que je me fous g5
j'aime j'aime ça c'est mal un jeu tu
fermes se fout de cases blanches
tentative est fermé ah ok intéressant
intéressant on va voir on va voir
peut-être il faut c'est de jouer stouff
ici wes que caruana n'est pas
bon on a envie qu'elle développe fois je
crois et pendant qu'on parle je vois un
instant là nul de marc-andré à qui elle
a signé
sais pas ce que tu veux qu'on aille voir
sessegnon va y aller
on va laisser la caméra sion sur caruana
thierry bon comme on l'évoqué plus tôt
on avait laissé les joueurs dans une
position où a priori marque andriat bas
il était très souliers il avait un petit
plus grâce à de meilleures structures
pas 3 s'inquiéter
et donc ce avec l'année bien ça nous
surprend pas et roanne lamic un joueur
qui fait quand même beaucoup de duels
surtout avec les pièces noires
mais c'est quand même plutôt une bonne
opération pour le français parce qu'ils
stoppent l'hémorragie de défaites j'en
étais à trois de suite
tu avais joué cavalli jeunes ici pour
chasser le foot
ça reste quand même difficile de
presser plus
wii se répéter répéter comme ça alors il
avait il a changé c'est les noirs sur
vous le jeudi
mai au quai c'est assez curieux
l'impression que les noirs n'ont pas
trop trop de choses à faire je joue je
pense surtout sur le fait que son
adversaire est enfin pourvoir très
difficile
ouais c'est vrai et finalement ils
acceptent là dessus c'est sûr qu'à la
ligue 2 donc
oui position voyez un évidement
inégalités matérielles l'adaptant doublé
certes mais ils sont recentrés contrôle
beaucoup de cadres ils sont très solides
et aucun des deux camps peuvent vraiment
perdu d'avancé de perse et non parce que
celui qu avant celui qui va se créer des
ses plaies ce qui va se faire des trous
donc personne ne toucher à rien et un
statu quo dans la colonne sel et bas
face à l'évidence les deux joueurs
pourraient faire l'affairé farewell
baisse est assez logique annecy
ouais
ok bon en tout cas c'est un bon résultat
de la part de marc andré a on espère que
ça va le relancer un petit peu et le
jour à terrace office que tu peux
regarder deux sur leur passage alors va
geler de suippes l'a donc devant le
congrès aura les crocs allemand noir
aura le noir contre de grands maîtres
philippin nguyên thaï die bahn ok pas
d'appareil passé à
qui pour l'instant est à + 2 dans le
besoin qui a marqué deux points et cédé
nul donc on
le place au
centre
pas évident mais ok bon ben on va déjà
vu un marc-andré aph nous faire des
belles remontées bien sûr on va voir un
peu ce que ça donne
alors
qu'est ce qu'on pourrait aller voir est
ce que est ce que les cours étaient
joueurs
c'est qu'on en est vraiment là ou pas
entre caruana est guéri normal en
surpoids jeu 3g 6 je peux encore g4 donc
ça ce cas il ya eu 6 3 il a joué g6 il a
défendu point f5 et on va probablement
voir voir g4 et comme utiliser f4 le
mans peau noire
4 parce que tourner à y voir la partie
devant le soir est parce que
il ya eu pas mal de ils peuvent pas mal
de changements google chose
dépassé déjà le rajout de tendons qui
sont en avance par rapport aux deux sont
beaucoup plus vite sa position avec
ferveur pour le co
un gros avantage additionnel
comme on était ici stouff
donc on disait qu'il y avait pas mal
d'idées stratégique à avoir donc y avait
là taux qui n'est en b1 pour préparer de
la rue de la colonne d eva aussi 3,3
euros 3 3 3 pour aller capturer le pion
à 3 tranquillement et il y avait aussi
des deux fous de foot g4 pour échanger
les fous de cases blanches ce qui
permettrait aux blancs d'oeufs pour
avancer efficacement chaque cavalier
donc en tout cas c'était vraiment une
prometteuse ouais de carats qui orne son
reste donc du coup qu'est ce qui s'est
passé juste un an rojas les points noirs
gare déception un peu faible et les
cavaliers battre dufay a donc on va
aller un peu vite sur ce qui s'est passé
donc donc c'est assez logique donc qu'il
a mise à tomber un
revenu sur un projet du centre pour
aller parler d'efforts dans les pionts
tour 3 donc cette fameuse main d'oeuvre
on a évoqué pour taper sur 1 4 qui est
très logique ici
ces sept ça chapeau c'est juste pour
gagner du temps dans
neige
heureusement voilà on joue un peu car
hakim qui fut une feinte on sait qu'il
aime beaucoup faire mieux mais là on n'y
a aucun intérêt évidemment répéter les
secours non mais là ce que la six points
réussis c'est que moi je paye ce qu'il a
toujours envie de jouer
donc le food et c'était parti et jusqu'à
monde en parlait plutôt le fun section
se débattre du cannabis qui pourrait
sembler une bonne chose d'en avoir un
deuxième un monstre qui va surgir ans et
où il faut te jugera les gaz et surtout
il attaquera b6 des six même des fois et
pour aller au f5 bref ces cartes sera
très fort pas sûr car et qui n'a envie
de manger cavaliers p 5 non je pense que
c'est pas eu en son plan mais bon il à
faire signer quatre options c'est ce
qu'il a fait il a ramené ça il a remué
le
juste mot gestion déranger le pion et
après il va et après il va vérifier si
la a progressé au fur et à mesure what
les noirs n'ont vraiment rien à faire
donc c'est la section voile à neutre
effectivement j'ai fait un cavalier e 4d
tu bouges plus grand et rémy va être
perdu
ou deux câbles et fils force et moi j'ai
dit on prend notre temps en + 3g de ses
importants on défend l'entourage croit
maintenant que le fou était parti en
vaut deux
des huit tours h 1
il a tout le temps du monde en fait si
ce fait est très bien les torsions vouée
à la défense du psion qu'avec les bras
elle peut torturer son adversaire
cas d'allergie lui
ça y est c'est fait alors important bien
sûr reprendre la tour sombre est une des
pièces va se retrouver
je sais pourquoi elle pourra bouger
ses fesses à
24.4 tranquillement revenir
chez lui on essaiera l'adav en sélection
il peut jouer sur les deux ailes en plus
il est plus que cela
mais non mais c'est ça c'est un serment
ça va être une mort lente un vraiment
pour pour pouvoir reste c'est une grosse
torture un
lacet semblant de s'activer mais il se
fait chasser immédiatement et ça
n'arrivera plus à tour ne rentrera plus
c'est vraiment cette position quand on
est là qu ariane il va tranquillement
adversaires jusqu'à la victoire
certainement dans le forez ce qui va
tenter de faire un blocus c'est sa seule
chance pour moi il est dominé
à cannes en 2007 ce serait une bonne
idée pour lui pour vraiment contrôler la
cada sac mais m un accablant bz c'est
pas une tâche facile
comme ça
déflation de bon sens du cavalier en f 7
8 1 2 3 4 5 coups et pendant ce temps là
puisqu'il y avait des parents et astrid
je pourrais jouer h 4 donc non vraiment
la position est très difficile
là c'est une torture gratuite partout
kevin sinon la bulle tard 10 mai série
de raisons sont pour la chance de gagner
votre corps est même sera de même de
même retenir sa maladie qui suit la
valeur très dur très dur et du coup et
tu vois c'est là où c'est dommage j'ai
fait une bonne avec les noirs confort
est super mais ses parts à compenser cet
arrêt contre 7 c sur mais bon c'est
comme ça partouche ne propose pas y
avoir doublé si bien qu est-ce que j'ai
l'impression que l'échiquier série my
way et sur les acquis qui a une position
assez bonne
par contre tout à l'heure alors on
l'avait laissée ici
exactement ici il a réussi à priori à
s'en sortir or comme pour ses 5 a été
joué
mais quelle est l'idée sur
ton point de la
dame mettront et c'est comme tout à
l'heure en fait ouais
tour ainsi ça a été jouée
fois jouer
donc j'ai cavaliers 3 qui arrive aussi
précise bien joué
puissant mais il change de change sa
boîte à coudes épaules
on s'en va
mais aussi cavaler fois j'aurais joué
j'ai trois ou quatre jeunes français
non ma cave et l'effroi la logique on
bouge le cul on attaque le fou et là il
permet f-15
pas trop autorisé la musique
parce que l'idée en fait cela en
amérique s 4 pas très bon à cause de
cavalli qui vire en 4 1 4 6 pour le
canada après 84 mon jeu que j'ai
cavaliers f3 et tout mais j'ai plus la
casse pour le cavalier en tout cas c'est
être une querelle f3 s'est passé quoi la
torah guide
ok ok mais je
veux j'ai catastrophe
on ai parlé il faut du fameux g 4 h 3 /
/
/ f 4 mais la pression était différent
que le plus blanc étant deux dames temps
est froid et plus de contrôle sur le
terrain blanche
l'avait gâteau angers 6 le plantage 5
comprendre que ce soit un peu difficile
à faire il a joué maintenant
l'an passé il va y avoir pas pour ainsi
sous les 6 donc oui célarié voir le pays
donne l'option en disant je vais les
récupérer à 2 ensuite le pinceau comment
et c'est un go fidèle à son habitude qui
a réussi à
serrer la vis au bon moment
il croit d'ailleurs
tout reprend 1,2 waouh au tour 3 2 dans
ce sens là c'est
plus fort à la salsa sa force entre les
changes c'est très joli
est-ce que la place s'il est ce l'effet
dans l'autre sens c'est bien il y avait
le fou en prison b6 et c est ce que
révèle ans de pouvoir attaque de pro à
manger à deux et
côtoie déjà sleepers hobby ou
intermédiaires on l'avait vu tout à
l'heure on n'en parlait
et là sa force d'un point à 2 sur 6 d'un
travesti se défendrait la torah de
madame et pour prier ou deux seraient
imparable de cavaler derrière ça c'est
vraiment une c'est un projet 4 qui
serait qu'ils seraient très fort qui
arriverait donc là d'un point à 2 et
forcé
et et l'armée change tout et au final de
maintenance et noir qui ont encore passé
la vente à ce débat il va pourrir
davantage de clients peuvent
même pas d' attaque parce qu'il ya ce
courage les hyper et super g no
limit line doit primer des perpète n'ont
d'ailleurs b4y la fed à mettre cette
fuite mais
si c'est peut-être les blonds bruns qui
doit de faire attention à pas la perdre
bah j'ai un pion qui avance quoi donc
faut que tout cas tout de concret avec
l'élan récits ont fait la course tu fais
ce que tu cours justement
maintenant quelques années peut-être
aujourd'hui noms
d'animaux utilisés pour l'instant tu as
raison michel
pagé 5 g 5 pour les world va cette fois
ci très haut noir
mon arrivée à ses espions
j'aime bien ce qu
on fait un paquet de aussi un cas un
ticket qui force un peu les choses et
aya un père
patrick et les cinq heures
paris nice n'ont jamais vue d'améliorer
ça me
fatigue
2008 et
est dommage cinq échecs roi g8 des huit
et on fait
aller retour ce n'est pas sur l'issue
d'un joli la station ce qui va se passer
non parce que c'est possible
parce que d'un petit des packs
ok mais c'est la même non
non je suis à ma chute
je me mettrai peut pas jouer le match de
l'allemagne tout à l'heure ça lui ces
bâtisses c'est à toi donc donc dames
c'est ça montre aussi l'ambition de
ses biens aux critiques il a peut-être
une chance à jouer tout pour le game
aide à ces dames
airwatch 3 40e coup atteint par daniel
du boeuf
en disant que maintenant sur des
problèmes de bayas provient de voir
et il n'y a plus la dame là je cavale
est il venu de match 3 aura droit
d'accès à partir mais j'ai avoir froid
il s'est levé notre province et ça va
sûrement se terminer par la nulle en
juste après ce sera joue tant parce que
comment on peut essayer de pousser comme
c'est qu'on est trop faible sur case
blanche en paix tant pour les noirs
on pouvoir presser davantage
il semblerait le résultat quasi-nul
stadistes un quatrième nul de la journée
ce n'est pas d'hier pas voir que là on a
peut-être qu'un scène d'ailleurs je te
propose
de retourner voir qu'un sel parce qu'il
est entrain de la création et j'ai
l'impression que
libre s
weight peut-être le braqueur du jour
même si à 40 ans et qui risque d'être
très chaud
car est encore avec nous car il nous
donne
trois parties décisives en
l'envoyant quand ça ne commence à
évoluer quand même mon petit tour des
nuits ici
maintenance avec l'option il commençait
à devenir gratuit un bouquet de la
manger
de dames tactique l'attend et bouger
pour
b4y la même saveur me tiens en cette
fois ok
annonce alors c'est infini ce qu'il est
juste trop fort en fait
y'a pas de n'y a pas du tout contre ce
jeu là pour votre sensation
bon salaire difficile à avaler b6 son
pouce 4
500 chiens j'ai mieux genre ouais ouais
ingénieux mais elle s'est fait contre
eux chlorés
méchant oui
il faut un set
et tour séance l2 ya eu pour défendre la
tour qui menacerait maintenant de manger
le cavalier
est sûre cavaliers c'est lui qui aurait
une dame prend à 7 tours france le
ministre a proposé le
hockey mais tout prince est de gagner
aussi la princesse avec cavaliers prend
et les tours j'ai fait ce que j'avais vu
ça gaillac laisser une part et pièces à
keswick d'une femme acquiesce ok bon
sens pour moi alors juste en a un peu
vite
anticipa je pense que l'abandon en fait
va arriver tout ça fait bon de richard
rapport à 15 mars à tours en scène pour
des clous et celle ci l'eau qui menacent
de manger maintenant ce cavalier est le
seul coup tu sembles sauver le cavalier
du toit défendant la dame va perdre sur
le ch aura qu une petite tactique on
mange aussi vite qu'on mange le
défenseur de la dame qui peut pas nous
reprendre
et si les noirs très madame le temps de
des chaussures est sûre échouer à
remédier un
exactement et au passage notre tour
avancé changer la manger gratuitement un
cavalier donc là ça fait une pièce de
plus c'est la partie et je pense que
puel
invisible 26 coup tellement une victoire
tirman de quinssaines pas très efficace
au genre de rapport qui quand
l'ouverture bon ça paraissait pas si
dangereux car ça n'a juste jouer jouer
pour faire une partie d'échecs en fait
et j'ai vu aussi l'appariement de 20h45
si ça t'intéresse ben oui toujours
en fait personne morale et noir contre
petit prague
donc aussi un moyen pour lui d'essayer
de d'enchaîner les victoires donc rage
il y fait très chaud aussi mais c'est
quand même le le petit poucet on a bien
un de
leurs élus en encore des marches à
gravir avant d'attendre car voilà et du
coup
carson personnes décèdent par ses
clients ça peut vraiment de m pour un
bon mood pour enchaîner les victoires
ouais alors il n'y a pas d'ordre des
rapports avec et variés la joie vous
qu'on n'avait pas envisagé mais tu dois
perdre sur le champ et si je pense et je
vais fouler le 5 juin
alors on va regarder comme qu'est ce qui
se passe déjà sur la pro b 6 touches
d'un prompt à de jolis a bien sûr d'un
brevet cette thématique les deux hommes
sont reprises ou là le but c'est de la
sacrifier contre la plus grosse pièce
adverse possible et en l'occurrence ici
on pourrait sacrifier qu'on fait tourner
donc ça près partout les affaires cette
position est encore moins
avantageuse armée le pion béton
parce qu'on va voir moindre mal pour pau
rapporte qu'un scène il a répondu un
tempo dame c5 donc ils mentent sur leur
âge
mûr aliments et la robe nude race en
recettes et en à la nuance pas de bourse
tout c'est que surprise en p 6 tu prends
à deux francs le set tu crois à deux est
exactement on prend un c'est donc c'est
un jeune en impression se faire dans une
partie super gars il n'a pas le droit de
bavans j'ai joué un bon je mange sans
vos méthodes d'avant crise et
à la fin du mangement janssen et blanc
qui sortent avec le plus gros ventre et
du coup du coquin à cet ima qui va
gagner des matériels ce que regardent
et devant brise donc et la blâme aussi
et la dame aussi donc on joue sur le
chèque motivé la tour
échec il ya plus haut 4 et ab cette
dame je pense que il appréhender selon
par l'abandonner dans
leur petit spoil et c'est un coup de
bluff ça fait nul ça finit la canule
qu'on avait dix vingt premiers les deux
cavaliers de 5
cm d'aller boire mais juste voilà
m'avait prédit et là ça joue sajou dans
la partie d'un prend le set et là on va
voir comme si la caméra très très
bientôt vous allez voir rapporte rendre
les armes
je vous la suite bien sûr combien qu'on
vient dire que c'est de penser une
petite séquence tactique et élémentaires
pour des joueurs de ce niveau pour le
coc
rapport à capuche minutes à la porte de
la
victoire très convaincante 1 du champion
du monde qu'elle laissait passer des
occasions c'est des neuf dernières
parties aujourd'hui il a été
limité ouais franchement
ils remontent du rajout écrit
blendecques quand elle est blanche s'est
réjoui
d'avoir des regrets moment ils auraient
dû regagner l'une sur le dos je pense
à la literie l'attendu sabah rapporte qu
haïti vous verrez si vous voulez
abandonner dénonce t on a mangé la
bourse
thibault est ce que tu veux
et je joue pour jouer là ici
vous laisse regarder la caméra
comme c'est d'un procès de d'un pont des
huit on va avoir droit le
b777
et
[Musique]
et on voit pas trop trop
aux moyens pour empêcher la dame comme
dame b 2
mon rapport à terre c'est faux canadien
du mois une glace de la dernière place
d'affaires la recontre une simple avec
un roi parfaitement à la drire objet de
qui travaillent en duo
ils sont comme dame
b2g même d'être avec elle et ses 4 à
voir
ici que je
veux m'appuyer sans quoi être après rien
quand je peux pas trop manger mon
cavalier à cause de la promotion
mais
[Musique]
maintenant même en hausse alors
maintenant on apprend le fric
roi est très faible
et matériellement l'événement
d'envergure cavaliers coupions pour pour
la tour
vitrée pour un compte de ma gueule car
celle ci va rejoindre le groupe de tête
jusqu'à vide ce qui était en tête la
finul
mamediarov qui était en tête a fait
mieux il rapporte qu'elle surmonte est
donc était l'adversaire du jour de 15 7
et 15 scènes dont il se retrouve dans un
trio
trio infernal trio aucun des deux partis
aucun des joueurs testore de bras de
pouvoir attraper et aurait
alors donc du coup
il nous reste une ouest deux parties à
voir
ouais du coup le plus chaud c'est
caruana geek
parce que kara kim forrest c'est un
super avantage pour vos gars à grinder
afghanes qui avec à 1000 fois angers 4 1
qui allait changer maintenant le case
blanche ouais mais surtout ce taux
qu'ils ont passé la 40e alors qu'ici on
est en plein dans les notes donc ça va
être très angoissant as dit quoi jouer
les deux heures et deux minutes
respectivement ça va être très chaud
je retrouve la position on aurait été
donc un flash froid a dirigé six
semaines avait jugé 6 et comme attendu
j'écarte est envoyé par caruana veut une
grosse pression sur cette diagonale et
vu que la prise perdez sur le champ oui
vêtements avec des voyages de partout
donc c'est vraiment un il a joué
beaucoup rire il a joué f4 pour assurer
que ce soit 1,3 et on aime ça n'a pas
nui iv ou g5 et les gaz mais arrêtez un
peu réparer au le fou h7 les tristes
mais on en sort on bloque le fourrage 3
mais du coup et si carla a fait un petit
point intermédiaire avant de manger il a
joué g5 qui fait une découverte sur la
dame et sur la tour c 8 d'ailleurs
c'est un leurre de fer manager qui a
poussé s'adapte donc pas le choix
est parti en a 7 loin de son roi
est ici ici ici pour manger là il a
mangé la qualité langue et celle
matérielle caruana
il avait là bien raison on s'est vite
apparemment voilà mars est considérée
comme une grosse gaffe ok on craint
position est extrêmement complexe et
avec surtout pas beaucoup de temps la
pendule
j'arrive à me déçoit on appelle bourema
tour apparemment il ya peut-être qu'à la
dige 4 qui était très fort ici
le problème est que ce projet 5 je pense
qu'on veut jouer sur sur cannes noires
mais bon c'est parce que j'aime c'est
difficile c'est ainsi être quatre ans
que je m'attaque sachant que les ghettos
noirs sont partiront à 7 tout ça
toujours pas le matériel toujours
vraiment la taxe sur un point f4 attaque
h6 et ses angoisses et ses trésors à
c'est vraiment la ligne ordinateur
tandis que
ouais en tant qu'humain on voit manger
là pourquoi on
voit pas d'autres biens et immédiat on
va monter la tour il ya donc c'est le
choix de carbone amériques ce truc kg 4
mais surtout ce qui est quand même là du
l'envisager ladhuie penser ce qui est
très dur à avoir je pense est derrière
avec cette idée fausse et ensuite ce que
c'est quand même un coup
au kiel en apparence quoi et finalement
elle a le temps ici on crée des menaces
et un peu partout ah ok on va revenir à
la partie aux icedogs
qu'il a mangé la tour et de manière
intéressante
d'apparat manger le four il a bon j'ai
pu tous cavalerie qui était très
dangereux
je pense une bonne décision de guiry
stouff une boum avec lady cat bmw pas
voir et et sa conjointe a eu six
bolides et sur la crise
c'est de faire dans le premier set
et encore un joli coup race toof c'est
malheureusement pour les banques peuvent
rire cette diagonale
par enlever son propre retour et diabate
c'est devenu fou à 3 sur le toit ge
bâle ots et sur un tour c'est cette
carrière d'être le crew qui défend
justement j'ai et
j'avais pas bien fou j'ai vite
la foux gmc même des mêmes satlink j'ai
fini a été passé durant fait c'est
complexe
super chaud en marche - c'est hyper
compliqué
c'est là où les machines surpasse
largement les arts dans ce genre de
position
pour des pièces étaient cloués de
partout des faibles sur cases noires
ap l'ex
jeu j'actualise il a joué quoi ici sur 6
il a pas parce que vous savez la ville à
ses clients que simple la dame à 7
revient au jeu défensif seth
et montrouge et 5 bat au final des
champions 2-3 qui bloque la colonne le
jeu penser qu'on aurait dû le faire ici
vous projet sakhaline c'est normal et
encore un joli court de fabrice
ars option qu'il veut faire un point et
à tout prix
je prends un tokyo en 2 sets et c'est un
art dur passage de vitry
066 le roi qui va aller se cacher donc
ils joueront deux minutes chacun bref à
3 norman a il aurait six coups à jouer
3-0 40e coup et c'est hyper chaud si
perso avec moi j'ai l'impression que ça
commence bien sûr je vois la bagnole
allusion au mot sera beaucoup aimé
danois parce que l'attak blanche
finalement elle en train de senna
pourrait il ya deux pions pour la
qualité
et
y las vegas elles font des deux qui fait
la gueule je m'inscris en 3-4 belfort et
rien d'autre à
un mauvais fou devient toujours bon que
je te dis que le fou h7 va arriver en
1/4 un jour il va faire mal on n'est pas
là
non cet échange est aussi mais bon
chaque note très intéressant et très
tendu entre carmaux night day
il reste encore six courts il peut se
passer beaucoup de choses aussi coup
c'est plutôt qu' a priori qui tient la
corde ici
on va voir comment ça se passe
six jeunes autres cadres ou pas
forcément mieux
j'exige un petit coup d'oeil à son rival
en panne sur nous ce que tu fais
chérir la baisse pour l'instant a hélas
moins un bon tournoi et kara dax n'a pas
gagné la moindre partie de conclure les
deux hommes sont à la recherche de leur
première victoire cardin qui a fait que
des lieux et là où il a pris sa chance
aujourd'hui mais
ça pourrait bien se retourner contre lui
oui j'avais qu'il fallait prouver un
lycée 40 a aussi comme avantage heures
comme le point il est un des premiers ex
aequo du menteur at il
là quelques semaines même si à barbery
connaissait pas la règle et des partages
qu'il a fait nul son jeu comprend des
pommiers à dernier
parce qu'ils savaient pas que jean siens
4 ex-aequo il n'y aurait pas en effet en
départage c'est l'explication
résultats
tant qu'un fabiano caruana il a plus que
une minute quarante
élèves se rend compte qu'il a vraiment
des problèmes à la position
enfoncée ou c'est un peu être logique
pour essayer d'aller et aux 3000 rue
avait laissé quatre là il faut asseoir
la partie au gigot six cavaliers c'est
qu'après la russie logique harrigan